votre première
audition au sein de notre commission
dans vos nouvelles fonctions de ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse au nom de tous mes collègues
avec un peu de retard mais le calendrier
du Sénat en veut ainsi en est ainsi je
tiens à vous féliciter pour cette
nomination et vous souhaiter bien sûr un
plein succès dans cette mission dont
nous mesurons bien ici la complexité
comme vous le savez déjà monsieur le
ministre vous trouverez au sein de notre
commission des interlocuteur attentif
exigeant mais constructif soucieux à
l'image de notre rapporteur Jacques
groperin d'entretenir le dialogue avec
vous et vos services sur des sujets
essentiels pour les élèves et l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative je tiens je
pense en particulier à la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignement
en d'enseignant pardon sur lequel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années ici à la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire et au
cyberhcèlement sur laquelle le le Sénat
s'est penché en 2021 ou encore à la
politique d'inclusion scolaire par
ailleurs comme vous le savez sans doute
nousous avons créé avec la commission
des lois une mission de contrôle
disposant de pouvoir d'enquête consacré
aux modalités de signalement et de
traitement par les pouvoirs publics des
pressions menaces et agressions subies
par les enseignants dont les travaux de
cette commission de cette mission vont
vont reprendre et dans le cadre de
laquelle nous aurons également PLA
évidemment à à vous entendre mais notre
audition du jour
est est
consacrée au priorités que vous avez
défin dans le cadre de vos prises de
fonctions nous aurons aussi l'occasion
de vous entendre dans dans quelques
jours sur le projet Doig de finances
donc par conséquentes chers collègues je
vous demanderai cet après-midi de de ne
pas aborder les questions liées au
projet doit de finance puisque nous
aurons une une
audition d'ici quelques semaines
pouvez-vous ainsi Monsieur le ministre
nous présenteer votre feuille de route à
la tête du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale un mois et demi après la
rentrée pouvez-vous nous dresser un
premier bilan de celle-ci et des
premières mesures fortes je pense
évidemment à l'interdiction du port de
de laba ou du report des épreuves de
spécialité du bac au mois de juin que
vous avez été amené à prendre
pourriez-vous nous faire aussi un point
sur la mise en place du pacte enseignant
êtes-vous satisfait des des premières
adhésions des des
enseignants monsieur le ministre je vais
vous laisser la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes après vous avoir rappelé que
cette audition est captée et diffusée en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
puis ensuite comme il en est de coutume
je
donnerai la parole d'abord au rapporteur
que nous venons de désigner JAC gros
Perin et ensuite bien sûr à chacun des
des S chacune des sénatrices et chacun
des sénateurs qui souhaitera le faire
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
vous merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent à fond mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'avez dit c'est ma
première audition devant cette
commission mais en réalité c'est ma
première audition parlementaire depuis
mes nouvelles fonctions de ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
vous n'êtes donc pas en retard par
rapport au calendrier je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver beaucoup
d'entre vous avec lesquels j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler dans mes
précédentes fonctions au budget
retrouvver Jacques groserrin nous avions
tous les deux été rapporteurs quand
j'étais député de la loi sur
l'orientation et la réussite des
étudiants début du précédent quinena et
on avait eu une CMP conclusive ce qui
montre la capacité qu'on peut avoir à
travailler tous ensemble je vous
remercie vraiment de votre invitation à
m'exprimer devant vous dès la reprise de
vos travaux je profite également de
cette opportunité pour saluer et
féliciter celles et ceux d'entre vous
pour qui c'est aussi une première
audition dans cette assemblée ou au sein
de cette commission l'éducation
nationale est une préoccupation majeure
des Français à juste titre tant l'école
occupe une place singulière dans notre
société et dans l'histoire de notre
nation vous êtes le relais de cette
préoccupation à travers les travaux que
vous menez tant au sein de cette
commission que dans l'hémicycle c'est
donc pleinement conscient du rôle qui
est le vote notamment en matière de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
avec la plus grande rigueur que je
tâcherai à répondre à vos interrogations
aujourd'hui mais évidemment dans les
mois qui viennent l'école je le disais
c'est ce qui réunit les familles et la
République au sein d'une même espérance
commune que chaque enfant de France
puisse par l'école et grâce à l'école
s'élever et s'émanciper qu'aucun destin
ne soit écrit d'avance c'est la promesse
de la République et cette promesse c'est
celle de son école lors de cette rentrée
scolaire j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser
mon ambition pour ce ministère pour ces
quelques 12 millions d'élèves pour leur
famille et pour plus d'un2000 personnels
dont 860000 enseignants c'est chaque
année je le dis un petit miracle
d'organisation que cette rentrée
scolaire et je veux ici remercier de
nouveau très chaleureusement tous les
enseignants les directeurs d'école les
chefs d'établissements tous les
personnels des directorat qui ont uvré
pour cette rentrée je souhaite vous
faire part en introduction des échanges
on m'a indiqué qu'il fallait pas être
trop long pour qu'on puisse échanger les
chantiers que j'ai engagé dès ma prise
de fonction et d'abord en vous disant
que je suis lucide malgré le travail
conduit ces dernières années il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour réparer ce
que j'ai appelé les mots de l'école les
mots de l'école disons-le clairement
sont le fruit de décennies de
sous-investissement d'une absence de
reconnaissance de nos professeurs d'une
contestation de leur autorité comme plus
généralement de l'autorité des savoirs
dans notre société ils sont enfin le
fruit d'une école qui ne garantit plus
toujours le bien-être et j'ose le dire
le bonheur des élèves comme des
personnels voilà pourquoi j'ai fixé à
mon ministère trois priorités claires la
première élever le niveau général la
seconde réaffirmer les droits et devoirs
à l'école et la troisième bâtir une
école qui émancipe et qui rend heureux
ma première priorité c'est donc d'élever
le niveau par un véritable choc des
savoirs un mot d'abord sur le constat
mais il est hélas
connu notre pays a connu une baisse du
niveau général ces dernières décennies
un élève de 4e de 2018 avait le niveau
d'un élève de 5e de 1995 en 23 ans c'est
un an qui a été perdu quand on regarde
aujourd'hui les évaluations nombreuses
qui sont réalisées chaque année les
évaluations nationales que nous devons à
l'action de Jean-Michel Blanquer je dois
le dire nous voyons qu'un élève sur 3
qui rentre en 6e ne sait pas lire écrire
et compter correctement nous voyons que
un élève sur de en classe de 6e ne sait
pas dire combien il y a de quart d'heure
dans 3/4 d'heure nous voyons que à
l'occasion du brevet des collèges pour
les élèves de 3e 25 % d'entre eux on
moins de 4/ 20 en mathématiques au
brevet des collèges le 4/ 20 étant la
note la plus distribuée en mathématique
au brevet des collèges ce retard
s'accumule et se et se perpétue tout au
long de la scolarité c'est donc dès les
premières années qu'il nous faut agir
nous savons pour la maîtrise des savoirs
fondamentaux c'est dès le début de la
scolarité que tout se joue c'est dès le
début que l'on peut éviter un décrochage
qui reste un échec pour tous c'est dès
le début qu'il nous faut replacer au
cœur de l'école la notion d'exigence
l'exigence sans laquelle il n'y a ni
excellence ni égalité des chances dans
notre école républicaine pour cela mon
ministère dispose de moyens historiques
le projet de loi de finances pour 2024
que vous aurez examiné dans les
prochaines semaine prévoit une
augmentation inédite du premier budget
de la Nation je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail puisqu'on aura une audition
dédiée mais simplement pour donner un
chiffre que j'ai donné tout à l'heure
aux questions d'actualité au
gouvernement depuis 2017 l'école a perdu
300000 élèves du fait de la démographie
le budget augmenté de 30 % 300000 élèves
de moins 30 % de budget en plus ça ne
s'est jamais vu dans les dernières
décennies dans le quinquena qui s'ouvre
l'école perdra autour de 400000 élèves
du fait de la démographie qui doit
évidemment nous préoccuper une question
a lieu tout à l'heure sur le sujet et le
budget continuera à augmenter nous avons
amélioré le taux d'encadrement ces
dernières années nous allons continuer à
l'améliorer en 2024 ce ces budgets et
ces moyens supplémentaires nous
permettent de poursuivre un certain
nombre de chantiers d'achever à la
rentrée 2024 le dédoublement des classes
de grandes sections de maternelle en Rep
et REP plus ce qui permettra à notre
pays d'enseigner à 500000 élèves en
grandes sections CP et CE1 dans des
classes dédoublées précisément là où
nous devons briser les inégalités de
destin de poursuivre l'effort d'accueil
dès 2 ans en très petite section avec 60
dispositifs supplémentaires en quartier
politique de la ville soit une
augmentation de 50 pour de renforcer
l'apprentissage de la lecture et la
pratique de l'écriture dès le CP et tout
au long de l'école élémentaire il y a
urgence c'est pourquoi nous renforçons
aussi la lecture de texte long dès le
CM1 j'ai eu l'occasion de l'annoncer
l'écriture d'au moins un texte par
semaine en CM2 et les stages de réussite
durant les vacances scolaires dans le
cadre du dispositif école ouverte dont
300000 élèves ont bénéficié l'an dernier
les nouvelles évaluation nationale en
CM1 qui se sont déroulé ces dernières
semaines et dont les résultats sont en
cours de consolidation nous permettront
également d'identifier les besoins de
chaque élève pour mieux y répondre enfin
en 6e cela nous permet de déployer des
SEP rentrées une heure de plus par
semaine en français et en mathématiques
par groupe d'élèves réparti par besoin
parallèlement aux enseignements aux
classes entières pour des cours de
soutien ou d'approfondissement dans ces
matières fondamentales c'est la clé de
même que la généralisation des devoirs
faits en 6e qui permettent en moyenne
2h30 par semaine de soutien aux élèves
et je soulligne ici que ce sont les
élèves de REP et REP plus qui en
bénéficient le plus au lycée le
rétablissement dans le Tron commun de la
première générale d'unh30 obligatoire de
mathématique par semaine il faut avoir
la lucidité là aussi de le reconnaître
supprimer les mathématiques du Tron
commun a été une erreur de la même façon
positionner les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat général et technologique
en mars n'était pas une bonne idée on
l'a vu cette année avec une très forte
augmentation de l'absentéisme et
globalement de la démotivation des
élèves après les épreuves de spécialité
en mars puisqueune grande partie d'entre
eux savaient à ce moment-là qu'ils
avaient leur baccalauréat avec les les
notes des épreuves de spécialité et le
contrôle continu nous avons la lucidité
de le reconnaître et je le crois le
pragmatisme d'y répondre c'est pour
répondre à votre question sur cette
décision que j'ai eu à prendre dès ma
nomination vous le savez j'ai fait le
choix non seulement après avoir échangé
avec les organisations syndicales et les
représentants des parents d'élèves et
des personnels de rétablir ces épreuves
en juin mais j'en ai profité pour
réaffirmer que l'année scolaire doit
aller jusqu'au bout du mois de juin que
la reconquête du mois de juin est une
priorité absolue nous avons donc donc
positionner les épreuves assez tard dans
le mois de juin de sorte que dans les
deux premières semaines de juin tous les
élèves du lycée auront cours que dans la
deuxème quinzaine de juin il y aura les
premières et les terminales en épreuve
et que les élèves de Seconde réaliseront
un stage en entreprise en administration
en association ce qui veut dire que tous
les élèves seront mobilisés jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juin de la même manière
j'ai décidé de positionner les épreuves
du brevet des collèges le plus loin que
ce n'a jamais été au mois de juillet ça
a très rarement été au mois de juillet
pour que les élèves du collège restent
en cours jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
on ne peut pas ambitionner d'élever le
niveau en acceptant que l'année scolaire
s'arrête pour des élèves dès la fin du
mois de mai dans la voie professionnelle
la réforme que nous engageons en cette
rentrée augmentera d'un milliard d'euros
les moyens des lycées professionnels
permettra de développer les périodes de
formation des élèves en milieu
professionnel ces stages seront
désormais gratifiés de 50 à 100 € par
semaine ça permettra de déployer des
cours en petits effectifs dans les
enseignements généraux mais aussi de
créer de nouvelles options pour les
lycéens professionnels avec des cours
d'entrepreneuriat des cours de codage ou
des langues vivantes pour poursuivre
cette bataille des savoirs j'ai annoncé
la semaine dernière la mise en place
d'une mission avec des recteurs des
chercheurs des inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale des professeurs et
d'autres personnels de terrain qui me
remettront leur conclusions d'ici la fin
de l'année je le redis il y a urgence
pour élever le niveau et lutter contre
tous les déterminismes nous aurons je
l'espère l'occasion d'échanger sur cette
mission et ces recommandations
fondamentales pour l'avenir de notre
pays vouloir élever le niveau c'est évid
évidemment aussi lutter contre les cours
perdus pour les élèves l'an dernier il y
a 15 millions d'heures de cours qui
n'ont pas été honorés pour les élèves 15
millions d'heures d'absence non remplacé
on peut pas ambitionner d'élever le
niveau avec 15 millions d'heures de
cours perdu sur une année j'ai fait de
ce sujet une priorité sur ces 15
millions d'heures perdues la moitié sont
lié à l'organisation de notre système et
donc il faut éviter les absences
évitable en repositionnant les épreuves
de spécialité du mois de mars Au mois de
juin nous récupérons des heures qui
étaient perdues à cause de
l'organisation des examen j'ai assumé
j'assume le choix de positionner
désormais la formation continue des
enseignants en dehors du temps de classe
je dis pas en dehors du temps scolaire
et uniquement sur les vacances mais en
tout cas en dehors du temps de classe
c'est près de 2 millions d'heures de
cours l'an dernier qui ont été perdu du
fait de temps de formation des
enseignants sur le temps de la classe
pour ce qui est des absences qu'on ne
peut pas éviter il y en aura évidemment
toujours dans une administration 1200000
agents il nous faut améliorer notre
capacité de remplacement c'est donc pour
répondre à votre deuxème question sur le
pacte enseignant puisque vous savez le
pacte vise à mieux rémunérer mieux
soutenir les les enseignants qui
s'engagent notamment dans le
remplacement de courte durée il y en a
déjà beaucoup qui s'engageaient dans le
remplacement de courte durée ces années
précédentes en heures supplémentaires
ils seront désormais rémunérer 50 % de
plus pour ces missions qu'ils
effectuaient déjà jusqu'à l'année
dernière un enseignant qui faisait du
remplacement de courte durée était
rémunéré je crois 41 € brut de l'heure
avec le PACT enseignant ça passe à 70 €
brut de l'heure augmentation très
importante qui a vocation à ce qu'il y
ait évidemment davantage de remplacement
pour ces cours qui sont sinon perdu pour
pour les élèves vous m'interrogiez sur
la le déploiement du PACT j'ai eu
l'occasion de communiquer sur des
premiers chiffres mais qui sont vraiment
très préliminaire parce qu'il date de la
fin du mois de septembre plutôt la deème
début de la deuxème moitié de septembre
que toutes les académies n'ont pas pu
nous les faire remonter et que vous le
savez le recours au Pact dépend beaucoup
des protocoles sur le remplacement signé
dans chaque établissement et que tous
les établissements n'avaient pas signé
leur protocole et pourtant un enseignant
sur qu s'est engagé dans le PACT c'est
même un sur TR au collège et un sur TR
au lycée professionnel ce qui est quand
même assez loin des prévisions parfois
on va dire terrible qui était faite
notamment par certains observateurs ou
certaines organis syndicale moi je veux
les remercier évidemment de s'être
engagé dans le pacte enseignant j'aurai
l'occasion d'avoir un nouveau bilan
chiffré sur le pacte au retour des
vacances de la toussin et évidemment je
répondrai aux questions que vous aurez
sur ce sujet ma deuxième priorité c'est
de bâtir une école des droits et devoirs
c'est d'abord un devoir de
reconnaissance que nous avons et que
j'ai comme ministre vis-à-vis de tous
ceux qui font vivre l'école cela passe
en grande partie par la rémunération en
la matière là aussi nous tenons nos
engagements en cette rentrée les
professeurs sont rémunérés entre 125 et
250 € nets de plus par mois qu'à la
rentrée précédente septembre 2022
septembre 2023 et ce sans conditions il
y a eu deux revalorisations du point
d'indice une revalorisation socle en
cette rentrée ça fait entre 125 et 250 €
nets de plus par mois entre septembre 22
et septembre 23 pour les professeurs
néotitulaires qui démarrent dans
l'enseignement ils sont désormais
rémunérés 2100 € nets par mois c'est
même 2466 € en r plus avec ces
revalorisations inédites nous
effaçons en grande partie une génération
de déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs et nous revenons exprimer en
point de Smic à un niveau de
rémunération supérieur par rapport à
celui de l'an 2000 c'est la plus forte
augmentation de salaire dans l'éducation
nationale depuis des décennies j'entends
évidemment qu'il y a en grande partie du
rattrapage justement de ces dernières
décennies j'entends que pour un certain
nombre d'enseignants c'est encore
difficile mais enfin il me semble
important de reconnaître qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'équivalent ces 30 dernières années
d'augmentation salariale dans
l'éducation nationale que ce que nous
avons fait c'est depuis la réélection du
président de la République depuis la
réélection du président en 2022
entre mi-2022 et janvier 2024 Paris que
vous savez qu'il y a une dernière mesure
en janvier 2024 avec l'injection de 5
point d' indice majorés pour tous les
fonctionnaires mais qui bénéficiera
aussi au enseignants si on met bout à
bout ces mesures entre avril 2022 et
janvier 2024 c'est plus 11 % au global
en moyenne de revalorisation ce devoir
de reconnaissance nous le devons
également aux aesh qui accompagnent
chaque jour les élèves en situation de
handicap dans leur scolarité en cette
rentrée plus de la moitié des aesh sont
désormais en CDI ce qui marque notre
volonté forte de déprécariser ce métier
l'an dernier on était à peine en dessous
de 30 % d'Es en CDI par ailleurs toute
bénéficie d'une revalorisation de 10 à
13 %. évidemment si on veut
structurellement et véritablement
améliorer la rémunération des aesh c'est
sur le temps de travail qu'il faut jouer
si vous vous vous êtes à 24 he maximum
par semaine pour améliorer votre
rémunération il faut évidemment
augmenter le volume horaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
évidemment avec les collectivités
locales sur le temps périscolaire nous
travaillons aussi dans les suites de la
Conférence nationale du handicap sur des
missions supplémentaire qui pourrait
être confié aux aesh pour leur permettre
d'avoir un temps complet et donc une
meilleure rémunération mais nous
attendons pas ce travail pour faire une
revalorisation nous poursuivons
également l'effort de recrutement à
l'heure où je vous parle nos effectifs
et nos écoles comptent 15 à ESH de plus
qu'à la rentrée 2022 l'école des droits
et devoirs c'est aussi le respect de
l'autorité du maître et de l'autorité
des savoirs c'est le respect des
principes les plus élémentaires de notre
République comme la laïcité ces derniers
mois nous le savons les atteintes à la
laïcité s'étaient développé à un rythme
inquiétant que cela concerne la
contestation des enseignements en
histoire géographie en SVT ou dans
d'autres disciplines ou bien sûr le port
de tenue non conforme à la loi de 2004
vous le savez j'ai assumé une décision
importante au moment de ma nomination
une décision importante mais qui en
réalité n'aurait pas dû être vécu comme
telle puisqu'il s'agit simplement de
décider d'appliquer la loi la loi de
2004 ce qu' a confirmé le Conseil d'État
dans son avis qui a été remis suite aux
référés qui ont été conduits par
certaines associations sur ma décision
le Conseil d'État a confirmé que je ne
faisais qu'appliquer la loi de 2004 vous
m'avez interrogé monsieur le Président
sur la manière dont cette mesure s'est
appliquée je suis je dit très satisfait
de la manière dont cette mesure a été
appliquée nous avons eu sur la première
semaine de la rentrée scolaire autour
d'un millier de contestations de la
règle par des élèves ce qui est peu par
rapport au nombre de tenue non conforme
qui étit porté l'année dernière ce qui
montre qu'une grande partie des élèves
concernés s'était conformé à la règle
pour le jour de la rentrée et surtout
dans la quasi totalité des cas nous
sommes parvenus par la pédagogie et le
dialogue à a régler ces situations et
moi je veux vraiment rendre hommage aux
chefs d'établissement à leurs équipes
aux équipes laïité valeur de la
République des rectorats qui étaient au
côté des chefs d'établissement pour
engager ce dialogue et cette pédagogie
avec les élèves et les familles pour moi
ça montre que quand il y a de la
pédagogie du dialogue bref de l'humain
on arrive à gérer des situations tendues
et c'est pour moi un enseignement y
compris que je porte pour la question du
harcèlement scolaire ma troisème
priorité c'est enfin de construire une
école qui émancipe et qui rend heureux
s'émancipé c'est pour nos élèves la
chance d'acquérir une autonomie d'esprit
un esprit critique une ouverture
intellectuelle à tous les savoirs et au
monde cette émancipation passe d'abord
par l'enseignement des humanités et de
la culture générale c'est pourquoi nous
étendons à tous les collégiens l'accès
aux passeculture alors que plus de la
moitié des élèves de 4e et de 3e ont pu
bénéficier l'an passé d'une activité à
ce titre visiter un musée avec un guide
conférencier assister à une
représentation au théâtre pratiquer un
instrument de musique autant de
découvertes et de pratiques qui font
l'éducation artistique et culturelle de
notre jeunesse et que nous développons
en cette rentrée encore grâce à
l'extension du passculture collectif à
l'école nous allons également refonder
pour la rentrée prochaine l'enseignement
moral et civique j'y tiens tout
particulièrement l'école doit non
seulement élever le niveau mais former
des républicains pour cela mon
prédécesseur a saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes qui me rendra
ses propositions d'ici la fin de l'année
je veillerai tout particulièrement à la
place de nos institutions dans cet
enseignement à l'Enseign ement de la
laïcité et je sais Monsieur le Président
que la mission que vous conduisez sera
très utile là aussi pour enrichir ce
travail là avec le sujet de la BAA
évidemment on n pas réglé tous les
sujets d'application de la laïcité à
l'école loin de là je rappelle que dans
les récentes études encore un enseignant
sur deux déclare s'autocensuré notamment
pour des raisons de contestation de la
laïcité dois donc poursuivre et
j'attends beaucoup de la mission qui est
conduite par les sénatrices et les
sénateurs sur ce sujet je veux avancer
aussi sur l'éducation au médias et à
l'information dont nous percevons chaque
jour l'utilité face aux tentations de
l'instantanée et de l'immédiateté qui ne
remplaceront jamais l'esprit critique et
le débat éclairé l'objectif est que dès
la rentrée prochaine nous puissions
doubler le temps dédié à l'enseignement
moral et civique dès la 5e enfin je ne
saurais parler des droits et devoirs
d'une école qui rend heureux sans parler
du droit absolu pour chaque élève de la
République d'être en paix à l'école oui
le devoir du politique et de garantir à
chaque élève une scolarité sereine je
veux bien sûr parler du fléo que
représente le harcèlement scolaire qui a
déjà fait souffrir trop de nos enfants
et de leurs famillees parfois jusqu'à
l'irréparable chaque élève a le droit à
la parole chaque élève a le droit à
l'écoute chaque élève a le droit d'être
protégé voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
et avec lui j'en suis sûr une très large
majorité des membres du Parlement font
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyberhcèlement une cause
absolument prioritaire pour notre école
j'en ai fait en tout cas ma grande cause
pour l'école et je n'accepterai pas
qu'on oppose cette priorité là aux
autres que j'ai évoqué précédemment on
peut pas imaginer élever le niveau si on
a des centaines de milliers ou des
millions d'élèves qui sont malheureux à
l'école quand vous êtes harcelé le
harcèlement envahit totalement votre
esprit il n'y a plus de place pour autre
chose il y a plus de place pour les
apprentissages agir pour le bonheur des
élèves à l'école c'est aussi agir pour
élever le niveau parce qu'on leur permet
d'étudier et d'apprendre en paix
je l'ai dit nous devons profondément
nous remettre en question sur ce sujetl
y compris dans les pratiques qui ont pu
exister dès cette été j'ai publié un
décret pour que désormais ce soient les
élèves harceleurs et non les élèves
harcelés qui soient contraint de changer
d'établissement dès cette rentrée nous
avons étendu le programme phare pour que
100 % de nos écoles collèges et lycées
prennent pleinement leur part à une
démarche de prévention de détection et
de résolution de chaque situation
individuelle nous devons remettre de
l'écoute et de l'humain à tous les
étages des rectorats à nos
établissements dans chacune de nos
écoles dans chacun de nos collèges et
chacun de nos lycées de l'humain on ne
luttera pas contre le harcèlement avec
des plans ou avec des circulaires nous
réussirons et j'ai vu au Danemark mais
aussi dans certaines écoles de notre
pays de très belles réussites pour faire
reculer le harcèlement nous réussirons
si nous changeons profondément de
culture face au harcèlement et si nous
nous en donnons les moyens les décisions
que nous avons présenté avec la première
ministre il y a quelques jours vise à
traduire ce changement de culture ça
passe évidemment par la poursuite du
renforce la formation des personnels par
la sensibilisation des élèves et des
parents par le renforcement des moyens
humains dans les académies et la mise en
place d'équipes d'intervention
dédié le 9 novembre prochain se tiendra
dans tous nos établissements la journée
non au harcèlement et pour la première
fois dans notre histoire un temps dédié
sera consacré dans chaque salle de
classe à la prévention et au recueil de
la parole par ailleurs internet et les
réseaux sociaux ne doivent plus demeurer
des zones de non droit où nos enfants
naviguent en insécurité des formes de
cours d'école sans règle ni
supervisation par aucun adulte à cet
égard je me réjouis des amendements
adoptés par vos collègues députés dans
le cadre du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
ces amendements qui ont été adoptés il y
a quelques minutes à l'Assemblée
nationale permettront aux juges
d'interdire à l'élève harceleur l'accès
aux réseaux sociaux pour une durée
jusqu'à 6 mois sans préjuger de l'issue
de la navette parlementaire j'ai la
conviction que ces mesures sont de
nature à participer au renforcement de
la lutte contre le cyber harcèlement
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs les Français attendent
beaucoup de leur école et ils ont raison
la libération de la parole que nous
observons ces dernières semaines sur le
harcèlement démontre non seulement
l'urgence à agir mais aussi tous les
progrès que nous pouvons accomplir si
nous sommes unis pour notre école au
fond toutes les priorité de l'agenda que
je viens de vous présenter sont liés on
ne peut pas élever le niveau je le
disais si nos élèves sont malheureux à
l'école on ne peut pas élever le niveau
si nos professeurs sont malheureux
d'enseigner ne retrouve pas la fierté et
le prestige d'un métier si indispensable
en démocratie on ne peut pas élever le
niveau si on retrouve pas le sens des
principes à commencer par l'autorité du
maître et l'autorité des savoirs qui
permettent le progrès dans nos sociétés
pour conduire toutes ces transformations
je suis convaincu que nous saurons
trouver des points d'accord dans
l'intérêt supérieur du pays et de sa
jeunesse uni pour son école notre pays
n'en sera que plus fort et plus juste je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
première série de questions de notre
rapporteur budgétaire jacqu grerin qui
veillera ne pas poser toutes les
questions
oui j'ai bien compris monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci de
votre propos quel programme quel
programme et quel programme j'avais en
son temps lors de lors d'une audition
avec votre prédécesseur dit à votre
prédécesseur soyez ministre peser et
cetera je ne doute pas de vos
convictions de vos enthousiasmes de
votre énergie je voudrais tout d'abord
saluer ce qui n'est pas courant de la
part deune opposition politique mais
d'une opposition en tout cas
républicaine les gestes que vous avez eu
vis-à-vis de cette interdiction que vous
avez proposé et combien de fois nous
l'avons demandé au à votre prédécesseur
l'interdiction donc de la BAA et je
crois qu'un moment donné vous avez dit
vous avez assumé je crois que le terme
est bien é assumé la France en tout cas
les Français les chefs d'établissement
l'attendaient et et vous en remercie la
deuxième chose je voudrais aussi euh
vous féliciter sur votre prise de
position vis-à-vis des courriers
vis-à-vis de Versailles ce sont des
gestes qui ne sont pas anodins parce que
les parents vous écoutent vous entendent
et vous représentez le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et vous
représentez aussi quelque part la France
et enfin euh peut-être aussi vous dire
et et dans cette période singulière tout
à l'heure sur les question d'actualité
avec où il y avait beaucoup de d'émotion
la visite ce matin d'une école juive à
sarcell avec le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est un moment important qui est
regardé et c'est grâce à des moment
comme ça que vous pourrez que vous
symbolisez la République mais vous
pourrez aussi à un moment donné apporter
beaucoup de choses à la République et à
notre nation qui en ce moment souffre
j'ai entendu je serai pas trop long
parce qu'il y aura d'autres moments le
président l'a fort bien dit tout à
l'heure sur le sur sur en tout cas le le
financement de de de ce de votre projet
en tout cas de ce projet-là il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dite mais
simplement je voudrais vous alerter
faites attention au niveau de la
communication parce qu'à vouloir trop
communiquer à un moment donné on peut
perturber les uns et les autres on peut
perturber les chefs d'établissements on
peut perturber les enseignants on peut
perturber parfois les élèves et et je
comprends votre élan votre enthousiasme
et votre envie parce qu'on vous demande
tellement en même temps que c'est
tellement difficile et que vous avez
envie certainement de tellement bien
faire euh sur les les trois points
remettre l'aspect l'autorité savoir
fondamentaux on va pas refaire
l'histoire sur ce qui se passe en France
mais on aura quand même un
questionnement à voir un jour à ce qui
se passe véritablement en classe dans la
classe mais là il y a quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre du du chef du pas du chef
d'établissement mais de l'enseignant et
c'est pas toujours facile de mais
véritablement il faudra se poser la
question de ce qui se passe parce que on
a le premier budget on l'a dit tout à
l'heure 100 milliard mais je crois que
un moment donné on peut être aussi en
demande d'autres choses vous avez dit
garantir à chaque chaque élève chaque
jour un prof face à lui ça c'est
fondamental là je le relirai par rapport
à la formation continue lorsque vous
avez dit 15 millions odeur qui n'avent
qui ne sont pas enseignés dont 10 % dans
le casre de la formation continue vous
proposez que ça soit alors vous faites
la nuance dans le temps scolaire en
dehors de l'écolec et cetera je crois
que on a bien vu qu'avec la ministre
Belkassem même en posant à un moment
donné une rémunération même en posant
d'autrre chose ça n'a pas marché comment
vous allez inciter les enseignants
inciter j'ai pas dit obligé à pouvoir
fonctionner dans dans le casre en tout
cas de faire cette formationue en
sachant que les enseignants en France
parce que la priorité c'est le français
les mathématiques les enseignants du
français ont de fois moins de
formationue que leurs collègues de
l'OCDE vous n avez parlé faire une une
école ou un lieu où chaque enfant puisse
être heureux la lutre de harcellement
que vous ne concurrencez pas avec le
reste c'est fondamental mais je voudrais
faire référence à la médecine scolaire
médecine scolaire il y a une concurrence
très forte vis-à-vis de d'autres
organismes et on voit bien nous dans le
département du dou il y a cas emplois
ETP et il y a que cinq qui sont en tout
cas occupés quand je dis médecine
scolaire c'est aussi infirmierers et il
participe aussi au repérage vis-à-vis du
harcèlement la souffrance et cetera et
cetera donc ce sont des choses qui qui
me semblent fondamentales euh vous nous
avez parlé également des semaines
entreprise pour les élèves de seconde et
cetera alors ça c'est une période aussi
qui est à cheval entre les périodes du
SNU faisons attention le SNU a c'est une
priorité du président de la République
comment vous allez l'organiser pour
qu'un moment donné on puisse gérer cela
parce qu'il nous paraît important et ces
annonces ont fait qu'un moment donné il
y a une crise pas une crise mais ça crée
des attentes chez les personnels
d'éducation national ça crée des
attentes chez les entreprises et ça
prisqueà un moment donné de poser
problème et enfin sur le pacte
d'enseignement j'en ai parlé moi
j'aimerais vous parler de l'excellent
rapport et surtout proposition de loi de
notre excellent collègue Max Brisson
pour uneécole la liberté l'égalité des
chances la lcité dans tout ce que vous
présentez aujourd'hui dans tout ce que
vous proposez il y a des pistes qui sont
intéressantes alors je vais pas prendre
l'article 4 sur l'article 3 sur sur les
dérogations modalités d'affectation des
enseignants mais pour qu'un enseignant
fonctionne bien et puiss efficace pour
qu'il se sente bien mais l'article 4 qui
est la création des écoles supérieures
du professeurat des écoles parce qu'il y
a un vrai problème de la formation et je
pense que redonner à l'éducation
nationale en tout cas la formation
qu'elle reprenne en main cette formation
du premier degré avec cette création des
des écoles supérieures du professeur à
des écoles ça pourrait être aussi un
chemin que vous pourrez prendre pour
pouvoir pas conclure mais en tout cas
engager dans ce vaste projet cette
vaste en tout cas pardon l'énergie que
vous avez et en tout cas on vous
souhaite une grande réussite dans
l'éducation nationale parce que ça
touche grand nombre de familles grand
nombre d'enseignants grand nombre
d'enfants grand nombre d'élèves et grand
nombre de parents merci min je vais vous
laisser répondre aux questions du
rapporteur qui a déjà abordé un certain
nombre de de sujets
dans on va
dire merci monsieur le Président et
merci au rapporteur je vais revenir sur
les différentes questions vous avez
commencé par la formation continue moi
je le redis j'assume ce choix de
positionner la formation continue en
dehors des heures de cours pour limiter
au maximum les heures de cours qui sont
perdu pour nos élèves pour autant
j'assume de dire aussi qu'on a besoin de
formation continue évidemment qu'on a
besoin que les enseignants puissent
accéder et recour à la formation
continue
c'est pourquoi je pense que cette
décision peut-être une opportunité pour
améliorer le recours à la formation
continue parce que parfois en écoutant
certains débats ou en regardant certains
commentaires j'ai l'impression que
certains estiment que l'organisation de
la formation continue aujourd'hui serait
parfaite ou idéale il y a moins d'un
enseignant sur de au collège qui a
recours et à peine plus d'un enseignant
sur 3 au lycée qui a recours souvent
parce que ils le disent il y a de très
bons formateurs il y a de très bonnes
formations mais l'organisation elle-même
de la formation ne répond pas totalement
à notre attente on veut des modules plus
courts c'est câbles en hybride sur site
dans notre établissement en collectif
avec nos collègu et c'est exactement ça
qu'on va être qu'on va mettre en place
et qu'on est en train de mettre en place
raison pour laquelle la décision que
j'ai prise s'applique de manière
progressive il s'agit pas de dire on
passe du jour au lendemain à plus aucune
formation continue sur le temps de la
classe j'ai dit 30 % en cette rentrée 50
% au premier janvier prochain 100 % à la
rentrée prochaine ce qui laisse le temps
à nos écoles académiques de formation
continu au réseau canopé et autres de
déployer leur offre de la réadapter pour
qu'on puisse avoir un meilleur recours à
la formation continue sur la formation
initiale c'était la dernière question
mais comme c'est sur la formation je je
couple les deux oui il faut une profonde
réforme de la formation initiale des
enseignants c'est à la fois un levier
essentiel pour l'élévation du niveau de
nos élèves mais c'est aussi un levier
essentiel pour le bien-être de nos
enseignants et c'est un levier essentiel
pour l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant moi je crois pas du tout à
une crise des vocations je crois pas du
tout il a une crise d'vocation il y a un
étudiant sur 4 qui déclare être
intéressé par l'enseignement même 12 %
sur un gros volume qui disent envisager
très sérieusement de devenir enseignant
et par ailleurs on a tous autour de nous
des exemples de personnes qui à 30 40 ou
50 ans après une première carrière
parfois dans le privé ou dans le public
se disent j'ai envie de donner du sens à
mon travail et j'envisage de devenir
enseignant je pense au contraire qu'on a
plus de vocation aujourd'hui qu'on en a
connu c'est pas une crise de vocation
c'est une crise d'attractivité qu'on n
pas les seuls à connaître j'étais Bour
hier avec le président de la République
l'Allemagne anticipe peut-être jusqu'à
25 une pénurie de 25000 enseignants dans
les années qui viennent ils ont un
problème démographique qu'on n' pas
qu'on a moins mais ils sont font face à
cette difficulté au Canada il manque
5000 enseignants et aux États-Unis vous
avez des États qui réduisent la taille
des programmes dans certains états par
manque d'enseignant donc c'est une crise
d'attractivité qui est mondiale parce
que je pense que mondialement il y a
aussi une perte du respect de l'autorité
de l'enseignant de cette figure et en
fait une perte du du respect de
l'autorité des savoirs dans la société
la première expression de l'autorité du
savoir c'est l'enseignant si on ne
respecte plus les savoirs on ne respecte
plus
l'enseignant la relation entre un
enseignant et ses élèves ça n'est pas
une relation d'égal à égal il y a celui
qui sait et il y a celui qui apprend et
la relation entre un enseignant et les
familles n'est pas non plus une relation
d'égal à égal et je pense que c'est
toujours important de le rappeler et de
le redire en tout cas nous politiques on
a cette possibilité par ce discours
quand même de rappeler des choses qui
nous semblent à nous évidentes mais qui
malheureusement ne sont plus totalement
pour tout le monde c'est ce que disent
eux-mêmes les enseignants ensuite sur
l'attractivité il y a la question de la
formation
initiale aujourd'hui vous avez des
enseignants qui sont formés au niveau
master avec un concours à bac + 5 et
pourtant vous avez un enseignant sur 5
seulement qui se dit suffisamment formé
à la gestion de sa classe pourtant il y
a des difficultés on le sait parfois et
pourtant on a une année de m2 qui par le
positionnement du concours en bac + 5
est devenu beaucoup trop chargé ça
réduit le vivier les les étudiants M de
il cumuent l'alternance les cours la
rédaction du mémoire il y en a beaucoup
qui démissionnent qui ne sont pas
titularisés donc on doit revoir la
formation des enseignants et notre
ambition je pense que ça rejoint la
philosophie de ce que vous avez présenté
dans dans votre texte c'est de créer les
écoles normales du 21e siècle avec une
possibilité on a lancé une concertation
avec les organisations syndicales par
ailleurs je discute aussi avec ma
collègue Sylvie retaillot évidemment
immédiatement concerné puisqu'elle est
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
avec une possibilité d'avoir un concours
positionné avant le bac + 5 compris des
bac + 3 et ensuite une entrée
progressive dans le métier qui permet de
garder le niveau master une partie des
recrutements qui pourrait être fait par
prérecrutement dès le niveau bac et
ensuite avec une une formation
extrêmement dense notamment sur les
fondamentaux et sur un certain nombre de
valeurs essentielles bref beaucoup de
possibilités et on en discute en ce
moment avec les organisation syndicale
euh troisème sujet que vous avez abordé
et j'accélère la médecine scolaire oui
on a besoin de micine scolaire et
notamment sur la question du harcèlement
parce qu'on sait il y a des élèves qui
ont du mal à parler à leur enseignants
qui ont du mal à parler au chefs
d'établissement qui ont du mal à parler
à leur famille et parfois les personnels
sanitaires ou sociaux c'est des voies ou
des oreilles à qui les élèves se sentent
de parler et oui on a une vraie
difficulté et là aussi c'est une
difficulté d'attractivité puisque vous
l'avez dit les postes sont là mais ils
ne sont pas pourvus sur les médecins on
sait on a un problème global de nombre
de médecins dans notre pays et il ne
sera vraiment résolu que dans quelques
années quand les mesures qu'on a assumé
au début du précédent quinena sur le
numerus closus commenceront à produire
leurs effets avec les étudiants
concernés qui arriveront sur le terrain
et d'ici là je pense qu'on doit inventer
aussi de nouvelles manières de
travailler faire coopérer davantage nos
établissements scolaires avec la
médecine de ville avec les
établissements de santé et y compris
pour les infirmières scolaires moi je
pense que ça peut aussi être un levier
d'attractivité pour une infirmière
scolaire que de se dire je peux occuper
un emploi public dans un établissement
et en même temp temps avoir une activité
en libérale à côté si je le souhaite
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
donc on est en train de travailler à ces
solutions il y a beaucoup d'efforts qui
ont été faits sur la rémunération des
personnels de santé à l'école ces
dernières années avec un réhaussement
des gris indiciaires avec la prime pour
les REP REP plus qui leurit maintenant
versé depuis janvier dernier il y a
peut-être encore des efforts à faire on
va regarder mais en tout cas il me
semble que c'est pas uniquement la
question financière qui nous permettra
de répondre à cet enjeu enfin dernier
point sur la question du stage pour les
élèves de seconde d'abord il est très
important et moi j'y tiens beaucoup les
pays qui réussissent mieux que nous sur
l'orientation on prend l'exemple de
l'Allemagne de la Suède des Pays-Bas
c'est des pays où il y a 3 4 semaines de
stage nous là on dit juste on rajoute de
semaines en seconde en plus de la
semaine en
3è alors oui c'est un défi parce qu'ils
réaliseront tous leur stage au même
moment c'est pour ça qu'on va devoir se
mobiliser j'ai vu la présidente Carole
Delga des régions de France François
bonau renaom olier les présidents de
régions sont très engagés sur ce
sujet-là ils l'ont dit il y aura une
vraie mobilisation de leur part du tissu
économique les présidents de région
eux-mêmes demandaient la mise en place
d'un stage en seconde donc ils ont été
exaucés et évidemment ils se
mobiliseront j'ai eu les présidents de
fédération du patronat aussi qui se
mobiliseront c'est dans leur intérêt que
de faire découvrir aussi leurs métiers
leurs entreprises à nos élèves on
mobilisera les administrations pour leur
proposer des stages s'agissant de votre
question sur le l'articulation avec le
SNU évidemment des élèves qui
réaliserait le SNU à ce moment-là seront
dispensés de réaliser un stage mais on
les leur proposera de réaliser un stage
à un autre moment et on les accompagnera
pour ça donc il y aura pas de
concurrence entre les
dispositifs alors nous allons prendre
maintenant la première série de
questions vous êtes très nombreux à
vouloir poser une question ce qui est
très bien par contre je vais vous
demander d'être très incisif et d'aller
directement à la question pour que
chacun puisse s'exprimer on va prendre
un représentant par groupe je vous donne
dans l'ORD ordre de prise de parole
comme ça vous pouvez vous préparer
marie-pierreemier Lord Arcos George
laelc Max Brisson Sonia de
lapruté Monique dearcou Bernard fialer
Samantha casebon et emmeric
Durox merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors vous venez monsieur de Monsieur le
Ministre de nous refaire les annonces
qui ont marqué la rentrée scolaire un
empilement d'annonce j'ai envie de dire
que l'on a du mal à interpréter
autrement qu'une tentative peut-être de
diversion dans un contexte où la
première promesse qui devrait être celle
de l'école promesse d'ailleurs martelée
depuis plusieurs mois par l'exécutif
c'est de garantir la présence d'un
enseignant devant chaque élève et la
promesse n'a pas été tenue face à la
fragilisation sans précédent de notre
école laïque publique et républicaine il
est plus que jamais nécessaire de
restaurer la confiance vous avez parlé
d'humain mais il faut restaurer la
confiance et le dialogue avec tous les
membres de la communauté éducative
alors que au contraire vous faites le
choix d'une démarche très verticale
souscouvert vous en avez reparler de
groupes de travail à qui sont alloué si
j'ai bien compris 8 semaines seulement 8
semaines pour relever le défi de
l'amélioration du niveau des élèves vous
parlez de concertation auprès de
l'ensemble des enseignants mais les
lignes directrices sont connues d'avance
dans notre rapport bilan des mesures
éducatives du Kena publié en février
2022 et mené avec mes collègues Max
Brisson niigbillon nous pointions les
dérives d'une politique publique mené
dans la précipitation et à la mise en
œuvre mal accompagnée j'ai bien peur que
ce nouveau quinquena ne tire pas la
leçon des erreurs commises précédemment
mes questions m'ont porter d'abord à
nouveau sur la pénurie d'enseignant et
je parle d'une enquête qui a été faite
par le
nspd UNSA qui pointait le manque de de
plus d'un enseignant dans 58 % des
collèges et des lycées à la rentrée et
je vous le dis à ce jour j'ai encore des
mails de différents établissements où
ils me disent qu'il manque d'enseignant
quelles sont les solutions prévues pour
garantir une présence d'un enseignant
qualifié devant les élèves et j'insiste
sur qualifier parce que c'est un
préalable indispensable pour garantir
l'éducation de nos enfants dans de
bonnes conditions dans un collège de
Gironde c'est le proviseur qui a publié
des petites annonces et envoyé des une
lettre aux parents d'élèves pour qu'on
lui communique des CV c'est ma collègue
Laurence Sibé qui m'en a fait
part comment faire face au déficit de
remplacement tout au long de l'année à
venir dans un contexte où comme vous
l'expliquiez vous-même dans une récente
interview au Monde les remplaçants sont
déjà positionnés sur des postes vacant
dès la
rentrée signature de contrat alors là de
grve dysfonctionnement en matière de
signature de contrat et de rémunération
des personnels non enseignants AED aesh
assistants ou assistantes social ou
sociaux des assistants administratifs
qui n'ont à 7 heure toujours pas de
contrat et pas de rémunération depuis
début septembre enrome la situation est
tellement dramatique que la commission
départementale d'Action Sociale a dû
hier attribuer des aides d'urgence à
plusieurs personnels à cause de
cela alors il y aurait plusieurs
facteurs le premier c'est peut-être le
manque de personnel administratif au
rectorat c'est aussi un nouveau logiciel
qui peut-être dysfonctionnerait ou
serait pas adapté mais il y a quand même
peut-être aussi
l'impréparation de la mise en place la
cédisation des aesh et des
AED est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
état des lieux à ce sujet et nous
indiquer comment vous prévoyer de
régulariser au plus vite la situation de
tous ces personnels qui ne peuvent pas
rester sans contrat ni salaire presque
un mois et demi après la
rentrée il y a aussi un problème avec
les assistants sociaux les contrats de
contractuel un CDD non signé conduisant
à des professionnels à nouveau qui sont
en train de travailler sans salaire hors
cadre légal pour le N il y a aussi un
non déploiement des moyens nécessaires
pour couvrir l'ensemble des besoins et
pourtant tout à l'heure vous avez
insisté sur tout le travail à faire
contre le harcèlement scolaire et ce
sont des personnels qui sont justement
là pour la lutte contre lecellement
scolaire
pouvez-vous m'indiquer comment vous
allez régoriser leur situation et vous
assurer que les postes doivent être
créés alors le pacte enseignant dernière
question dernière question mais
justement je reviens à la revalorisation
des
salaire vous avez en effet beaucoup
communiqué en disant que chaque
enseignant percevrait chaque mois entre
125 et 250 € net en plus mais c'est pas
vrai puisque la revalorisation du point
d'indice de la fonction publique et
d'autres avantages ainsi que la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat de
rentrée sont intégrés dans ce calcul la
hausse de 10
% pour tous les enseignants n'a pas été
honoré et donc ce Pact les remontées
qu'on a pareil du syndicat
snmpd et
UNSA disent que il n'aurait pas été
signé dans 30 % des collèges et des
lycées à la rentrée alors nous nous
avons une position très claire nous
sommes contre la logique du pacte
enseignant celle de fait de pouvoir
gagner plus si on doit travailler plus
donc comment et qu'il a il y a de
grandes disparités aussi au niveau des
territoires donc comment allez-vous
désormais assurer l'accès de ces
dispositif d'accompagnement de
l'ensemble des élèves sur le territoire
et je vous je vous alerte sur deux
points sur ce Pact il y a des
enseignants qui sont amenés à remplacer
des collègues absents pendant leurs
heures de service je connais le CAN un
documentaliste donc il est payé pour des
heures de travail effectu effectué
simultanément et des enseignants ou des
enseignantes effectuent des
remplacements dans des matières qui ne
sont pas les leurs trouvez-vous ces
situations normales et sont-elles
répandues sur le territoire merci vous
êtes une vingtaine à vouloir s'exprimer
donc si chacun prend 5 minutes on en a
pour plus d'une heure donc s'il vous
plaît soyez vraiment concis Lord Arcos
qui va montrer l'exemple de la concision
ou voilà j'ai j'ai le poids ou monsieur
le Président mais je vais je suis
content d'avoir le ministre en face de
moi parce que je vais quand même aussi
donner un un témoignage un peu poignant
une question d'abord très simple très
claire l'année dernière à la même époque
j'ai interrogé votre prédécesseur
concernant les maths dans le Tron commun
au baccalauréat parce que la réforme
avait fait en sorte qu'il n'y avait plus
de math dans le Tron commun euh ça a été
rétabli à moitié puisque ça n'est qu'en
première et en terminale ça n'est
toujours pas le cas et que du coup ceux
qui veulent poursuivre les mathématiques
en terminal se retrouvent en fait dans
des classes avec des matsp et des gens
qui sont beaucoup plus évolués en terme
de mathématique et vraiment je vous
assure pour être sur je dis devant aussi
mon collègue David Ross sur le plateau
de sa clé ça fait donc deux promotions
que nous n'avons plus assez de candidats
pour les écoles d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui
on va manquer d'éco de d'ingénieur moi
je me battais pour les femmes dans dans
le milieux scientifiques mais là c'est
garçons et filles et donc là c'est
vraiment un sujet quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grave parce que j'étais
très touché parce que vous avez dit en
disant faut que chaque enfant soit
heureux dans dans sa classe deux
exemples un premier je sais vous pouvez
pas changer la face du monde en en un
claquement de doigt qu' manque beaucoup
de CSH euh mais il manque aussi beaucoup
de place en imame et je vous le dis
parce que il faut aussi vous en parliz à
votre collègue moi j'ai à La Ville du
Bois un seul exemple deux enfants les
parents savent très bien qu' devrait
aller en imee et ils ont pas de place il
y a pas deesh et bien ils sont à l'école
de La Ville du Bois on les appelle les
enfants du couloir depuis le début de
l'année ils serent dans les couloirs
parce qu'ils ne tiennent pas en place et
qu'aujourd'hui et ben ils sont dans les
couloirs à déambuler euh devant leurs
petits camarades et je pense que ça
c'est absolument intenable deuxième
témoignage qui me tient particulièrement
à cœur Célian et eveve sont dans un
lycée à
d'ourdan en première STMG et depuis 15
jours ils subissent un harcèlement
scolaire absolument épouvantable ils se
réfugi au dans le CDI pour à l'heure de
la récréation ou du déjeuner pour ne pas
subir de d'insultte euh
le le proviseur a refusé de recevoir et
les parents j'aurais demandé de
d'appeler le
3618 on a eu une empathie formidable
c'est-à-dire un mail avec les médiateurs
de du directorat de Versailles voilà
leur numéro de téléphone et si ça va pas
appeler le ministre joigz le ministre
j'en ai parlé à Charlotte cobel parce
que c'est aussi son problème mais j'en
ai parlé à la daen la daen a dû sûrement
remonter les bretelles du profis
qui n'a rien trouvé de mieux que
d'exposer ses deux gamins devant la
classe parce qu'en fait c'est pas un
harcèlement de deux deux élèves contre
deux élèves c'est un harcèlement de deux
élèves contre l'ensemble de la classe
parce qu'ils veulent travailler et la
seule chose qu'on leur a dit c'est euh
vous avez une bonne éducation vous venez
d'ailleurs du privé eux vous comprenez
les pauvres ils n'ont pas de code donc
il y a du racisme anti blanc et du
racisme entre guillemets intellectuel en
fait on les traite d'un Tello et ils
veulent pouvoir travailler donc ces
enfants sont aujourd'hui chez eux parce
qu'ils ont été arrêtés ils vont suivre
une psychothérapie et il demandent
qu'une seule chose c'est changer
d'établissement pour cette fois-ci je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est mieux que
ça soit le harcellerur qui quitte la
classe mais dans ce cas-là je vous en
conjure essayer de m'aider pour queil
puisse changer d'établissement George
laelleec merci monsieur le président
monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi de me présenter
je suis sénateur des codes d'armeur et
pardonnez-moi aussi de le dire ici je
suis le fils d'un ouvrier agricole et
d'une ménagère sans
profession habitant à 4 km
du du bourg d'une commune de 570
habitants je dois donc à l'école de la
République d'avoir fait de moi ce que
modestement je
suis mes premiers mots sont donc des
mots de reconnaissance pour la grande
institution dont présidez vous présidez
la destinée et c'est donc avec respect
et solennité que je m'adresse à vous
monsieur le ministre alors s'il est vrai
que l'école ne peut pas tout il n'est
pas moins vrai que l'école peut beaucoup
et notre société en attend beaucoup je
voudrais
commencer par vous donner acte d'un
certain nombre d'annonces que vous nous
avez fait dans votre propos liminaire et
d'un certain nombre d'infléchissement
que vous avez apporté je pense par
exemple au mathématiques qu'on
réhabilite un peu
donact mais il y a deux points
particuliers qui ont retenu mon
attention le premier point c'est celui
de la dite carte
scolaire carte scolaire à laquelle nous
avons été confrontés dans bon nombre de
nos territoires et en particulier dans
nos territoires
ruraux parce que vous le savez nos
collectivités s'engage
beaucoup notamment en créant ces RPI ces
regroupement pédagogiques intercommunaux
d'ailleurs qui constitue peut-être un
bout de réponse à la crise de la
démographie dont vous parliez dans vos
propos liminires donc autrement dit on
vise un objectif de qualité on se
rassemble on mobilise bien au-delà
d'ailleurs de la communauté éducative
les familles les collectivités et cetera
et s'agissant de ces fameuses cartes
scolaires je me demande si préalablement
à toute
restructuration s'il ne serait pas mieux
d'engager en
amont une démarche visant la recherche
de la qualité éducative du à tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que plutôt que d'être
dans une logique d'application des
quotients mathématique la règle de
3 consistante à vouloir mettre en
adéquation je dirais les effectifs et
les effectifs scolaires et le nombre
d'enseignants si en amont nous engagions
une démarche visant une offre éducative
de qualité ce serait une bonne manière à
mes yeux mais manière d'aborder la
qualité éducative dans le dans le monde
rural
notamment en second lieu mais ça a été
abordé à l'instant comme vous je
considère que nous sommes confrontés à
une crise de l'attractivité des métiers
de l'enseignement par conséquent nous
sommes preneurs de toutes les précisions
que vous pourriez apporter et il me
semble que la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales est l'élément
quand même le plus déterminant pour
obtenir le consensus que vous recherchez
merci de votre attention Max
Brisson monsieur le Président je vous
promets de pas être plus long que la
représentante la porte-parole du groupe
socialiste
euh monsieur le ministre je serai dans
la bienveillance mais ne vous y habituez
pas trop et je tiens d'abord au nom des
sénatrices et sénateurs les républicains
à vous féliciter et pour votre
nomination de grelen et pour la rentrée
remarquez que vous avez faite avec un
discours qui
tranche avec le nom avec celui de votre
prédécesseur de votre éphémère
prédécesseur mais Jacques groperin l'a
dit mieux que moi pour répondre à la
demande de notre Président je voudrais
vous interroger sur quatre sujets la
laïcité l'école en milieu rural la
formation des professeurs du premier
degré même si vous avez dit déjà
beaucoup de choses et l'entrée dans le
métier d'enseignant tout d'abord la
laicité pendant des mois face au
chiffres préoccupant voir alarmment du
nombre d'atteintte à laïcité nous avons
exhorté sans relâche votre prédécesseur
agir comme l'a dit jacobin les voix des
chefs d'établissement des professeurs
étaient nombreuses pour réclamer des
instructions précises et un cadre
clair je salue donc votre décision et ce
que vous avez développé et mis en œuvre
avec courage mais je souhaite vous
interroger sur trois sujet rapide ce
matin vous étiez dans une école juive et
je vous en
remercie mais la question que je vous
pose ce sont les mesures que vous allez
prendre pour que les enfants de religion
juive ou de culture juive puissent sans
danger fréquenter les écoles publiques
les écoles de la République et ceci dans
tous les quartiers je pense que c'est un
enjeu majeur de laïcité la deuxième
question que je vous poserai sur laïcité
elle elle att trait à la neutralité
religieuse et politique des
accompagnateurs lors des sorties
scolaires une sortie scolaire est en
effet un temps qui rentre dans celui de
l'enseignement une forme d'école hors
les murs une classe hors les murs il
semble donc nécessaire que comme tous
les collaborateurs occasionnels du
service public cette neutralité soit
appliquée quelle est votre position sur
le sujet vous qui avez manifesté déjà
des positions sans ambiguïté sur la
laïcité mon troème point portera sur le
Conseil des Sages de la laïcité il a été
bousculé par votre prédécesseur sa
saisie n'est désormais possible que par
le ministre il ne peut plus s'autoaisir
l'élargissement de son périmètre à la
lutte contre le racisme et antisémitisme
et toutes les formes de haine et de
discrimination à l'égalité femme homme
et la promotion du principe de
fraternité à l'école a dilué le rôle
précieux que lui avait conféré
Jean-Michel Blanquer prévoyez-vous de
revenir sur ces évolutions du conseil
des sages de la
laïicité le deuxème sujet porte sur
l'école rurale je vais rejoindre
ce qu'a dit notre collègue du groupe
CRCE je voudrais vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre que l'amélioration des
relations entre l'éducation nationale et
les maires ruraux passe par la
rénovation de du partenariat entre les
maires et l'école de la République c'est
un sujet
prioritaire je pense qu'une qu'un des
thèmes que vous devez porter c'est
établir une carte scolaire
pluri annuel qui s'inscrivent dans le
temps long on demande au maire de ce
pays de plus en plus de s'inscrire dans
des documents d'urbanisme qui leur
conduisent à voir loin et pendant ce
temps le daen ou ou l' vient à l'école
avec sa règle à calculer selon des
procédures dignes de la 3e république et
des règles de droit que dont je n'ai pas
toujours compris la totalité des entrées
mais je n'ai jamais été très bon en
mathématique alors quand allez-vous
penser ce système
surannée pour être en phase avec les
exigences de l'État en matière
d'urbanisme et surtout pour avoir une
approche particulière des territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui sont eux aussi des
territoires à besoin particulierers le
trème sujet porte la formation des
professeurs mon collègue groperin vous a
invité à de bonnes lectures moi ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est que le choc
des savoirs dont vous avez parlé nous le
partageons vous avez déjà développer un
certain nombre de discours qui vont dans
le bon sens vous avez pris des mesures
je pense à particulier au baccalauréat
qui vont dans le bon sens mais pour
avoir ce choc des savoirs il est
nécessaire de repenser en profondeur la
formation des professeurs du prer degré
et dans le prolongement des débats que
nous avons eu lorsqu a été examiné au
Sénat la provision de loi que j'avais
l'honneur de porter et dans le
prolongement de ce qu'a dit Jacques
rouperin ma question sera très simple à
quel moment et comment et comment et
pour répondre d'ailleurs à ce qu'a dit
le président de la République lorsqu'il
a parlé de la nécessité de former les
professeurs du premier degré dès après
le bac comment vous
allez faire en sorte que les demandes de
l'employeur qui est l'éducation
nationale soi première
par rapport aux injonctions des
universités qui n'ont pas depuis 20 ans
montré leur capacité à former les
professeurs du prier degré la question
est là la question est majeure vous avez
parlé d'école normale du 21e siècle les
écoles normales étaient à la main de
l'éducation nationale c'est le rôle de
l'employeur qui est ici en jeu après
tout les magistrats c'est peut-être pas
toujours une réussite sont formés dans
une école à la main du ministère de la
culture il me semble nécessaire qu'au
moins les form les professeurs du
ministère de la Justice il me semble au
moins nécessaire que les professeur du
1emer degré répondent aux attentes de
l'État employur le dernier
point et j'ai peut-être été plus long
que Marie-Pierre Monier et je vous suis
présente immédiatement mes excuses le 4è
le le dernier point le dernier po
monsieur le ministre comment allez-vous
mettre un terme et c'est essentiel pour
la revalorisation du métier dans
enseignant et son attractivité comment
allez-vous mettre un terme au bisutage
institutionnel que les jeunes
professeurs quand ils rentrent dans le
métier subissent après tout ils sont
d'abord bisutés par l'institution que
vous avez désormais l'odeur de diruger
je vouserci voilà voyez monsieur le
ministre que le respect de l'autorité ne
se pose pas que dans les salles de
classe ça fait 2 minutes pour C de la
provoté euh non je suis pas plus
obéissante que les autres
merci j'ai aucune notion du temps quand
j'interviens c'est pour mon voisin de
derrière je dis ça euh non merci
Monsieur quatre questions je vais je
vous promets je fais plus court la
première porte sur le pas de vague et
sur les violences envers les les les
enseignants un professeur sur deux a été
victime d'une agression se dit avoir été
victime d'une agression on a eu une
audition avec votre prédécesseur il y a
quelques mois euh et et clairement on a
du mal à voir que quels sont les moyens
la stratégie qui vont être mis en place
il s'était engagé notamment sur une une
étude un peu géographique et de
caractérisation des
agresseurs pour voir comment on pouvait
adapter notamment en terme de ressources
humaine et de compéten le
l'accompagnement de l'éducation
nationale et le pas de vague pour tout
vous dire des témoignages que j'en ai y
compris dans mon dans mon département
existe encore et on demande plutôt de ce
terre que de faire des vagues euh voilà
donc c'est un témoignage tout à fait
récent euh ma deuxème question porte sur
les écoles hors contrat elles sont
encore en augmentation de façon
exponentielle euh avec
euh en 3 ans euh euh une multiplication
énorme de de euh des élèves plus de
11200 élèves dans dans le primaire on
est passé de 49 à 6,2 % des élèves dans
les écoles privées euh par qui sont hors
contrat on a donc beaucoup d'enfants qui
échappent un peu au radar de l'éducation
nationale au sens républicain du terme
et sans jeter l'eauprre sur tous les
établissements quels ont été les moyens
et quel bilan vous tirez à la fois de
cette augmentation de l'école de la
scolarisation contrat et et et et est-ce
que vous avez identifié des pistes
d'amélioration car on imagine qu'un
certain nombre sont nécessaire pour
pouvoir prendre en compte ce sujet on
peut pas traiter les questions par
exemple de l' mais pas que hein il y a
les pédagogies alternatives et ne pas
s'enquérir de façon ferme de de ce sujet
ma trème question porte sur l'éducation
artistique et culturelle et donc le
fameux 100 % EAC que que vous
avez que vous avez évoqué où en est-on
et quel est le bilan réel puisqueà une
époque le AC c'était vraiment des
actions portées par les établissements
portées par les enseignants avec un
réseau d'intervenants et qui était bien
identifié et qui qui faisait fonctionner
un écosystème entre les collectivités
les structures associatives euh les les
les personnalités issues du monde
culturel et et et et l'éducation
nationale et on sait que le passeculture
a amené un filtre complémentaire et a
fait différer et a fait disparaître pas
mal d'actions et pas mal d'intervenants
surtout qui était très très investi dans
dans l'éducation des jeunes et qui et et
qui n'avaient pas démérité et cette
écosystème là le passeculture le
fragilise très clairement et donc il y a
un retour quand même à faire sur sur sur
cette notion euh et notamment si le
passculture est un outil et pas pour
autant une stratégie en matière
d'éducation artistique et culturel et
donc quelle est votre stratégie en
l'espèce avez-vous des priorités qui
sont identifiées et ma dernière question
parle porte sur l'expérimentation
euh et de la modification du Sonnage
d'éducation prioritaire une cartographie
nouvelle devait être mise en place des
nouvelles pistes euh des notamment des
propositions de suivi particuliers des
éducations des élèves relevants
d'éducation prioritaire qui n'étaient
pourtant pas euh dans des zones de
d'éducation prioritaire en fait toutes
ces sujets qui faisaient qu'un certain
nombre d'élèves qui pouvaient être
qualifiés éducation prioritaire n'étaiit
pas pris en charge dans les mêmes
conditions que euh dans dans le zonage
identifié donc où on en est de de ce
sujet je vous
remercie merci merci écoutez monsieur le
ministre bienvenue vous voyez que vous
avez un lot de questions euh moi je vais
être très courte je pense que vous
pourrez pas répondre aujourd'hui mais je
préfère la poser la première qui me
venait à l'idée c'était celle sur
l'empathie vous avez fait une des
annonces concernant l'empathie comment
comptez-vous les mettre en œuvre et
comment est-ce que ça sera avec
l'enseignement peut-être civique moral
et civique voilà c'est une question mais
cette rentrée ma question Estelle portée
sur cette rentrée scolaire avec des
élèves de 6e qui n'ont pas plus cours
plus cours de technologie cette heure a
été remplacée justement par une heure de
de mathématique et de français comme si
la technologie n'était pas également une
matière où on utilisait le français et
les mathématiques c'était une annonce
brutale qui a été faite par votre
prédécesseur sans aucune concertation
cette suppression de la technologie
traduit à mon sens une mes connaissance
totale des enjeux éducatifs du 21e
siècle cette matière est directement lié
aux enjeux numériques et climatiques
cette matière permet également de
susciter d' voocations pour le numérique
pour les sciences de l'ingénieur et pour
la voie
professionnelle auriez-vous l'intention
de revenir sur cette décision
comptez-vous renforcer alors sur des
autres niveaux après la 6e cet
enseignement de la technologie et
comment mais je j'accepterai que vous me
répondiez plus
tard bien
fialer merci monsieur le Président donc
monsieur le le ministre tout d'abord moi
aussi je voudrais vous vous féliciter
d'abord pour vos premières prise de de
parole et la réhabilitation de et même
que vous avez incarné l'autorité et osz
l'affirmer je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est ce qui et qui
passe par le respect des savoirs et et
des enseignants moi je autant il faut
une autorité quelque chose de de qui
doit pas imposer une rigidité si vous
voulez dans pour l'éducation nationale
et la coopération par exemple avec entre
l'éducation nationale les communes les
départements les régions est extrêmement
important on a vu sur pour les
départements sur la médecine scolaire et
tous les problèmes sociaux que portent
déjà les départements avec la PMI et
leurs services médicaux-sociaux de temps
en temps il y a redondance et même
parfois il y a une impossibilité d'être
très efficace puisque les les assistants
social sociaux des des établissements
scolaires savent pas forcément ce qui se
passe exactement dans les familles ce
que peuvent avoir au contraire les
services sociaux des département et puis
lorsqu'on a suivi des enfants euh depuis
presque la naissance dans la PMI on a
repéré aussi euh les handicaps et le
fait que ça puisse être suivi
apporterait un petit peu des efficacité
pour ce qui est de la ville il peut pas
y avoir des règles si vous voulez qui
sont appliquées par les éducate de rue
ou ou dans le périscolaire que M en
place les communes et d'autres à
l'intérieur des établissements et le
fait qu'il puisse y avoir vraiment une
une prolongation sera importante et puis
vous avez parlé l'action des régions
pour les stages pour l'orientation qui
est aussi quelque chose d'important donc
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose auquel
je je tiens un peu dans dans l'esprit
des cités éducatives qui ont fait leur
preuve quand même sur certains
territoires moi j'aurais deux questions
la première c'est vous avez parlé de
l'évolution euh de l'enseignement moral
et civique il y a une mission
d'information sur la culture citoyenne
d'ailleurs mené par Stéphane piennoir et
et et Cabanel qui va déboucher sur une
PPL que je rapporterai tendant à
renforcer la culture citoyenne et qui
revient quand même sur cet enseignement
euh moral et civique qui devraitêtre un
petit peu délesté de de de
certains enseignements qui qui relèvent
du code de l'éducation je parle des
geste du premier secours les infos
données sur le don d'organe sur la
sensibilisation des conduites addictives
et qu'on puisse consacrer un petit peu
plus de temps avec peut-être aussi des
programmes euh dont la rédaction soit
moins confuse et qui soit pas remis en
question chaque année pour que les
enseignants se les approprient
puisqu'ils ont changé une fois par an
euh ces dernières années et puis toute
dernière question qui me vient de du
président de de l'Association des mères
ruraux de mon de mon
département ce sont les règles de
participation des communes aux écoles
privées de leur communes euh vous savez
quel le calcul est fait par la
division des coûts par élève de l'école
publique qui doivent être versé l'école
privée ils sont confronté actuellement à
une augmentation des coûts de des
matières énergétiques qui sont
importantes lorsque le nombre d'élèves
diminue quand vous avez une classe de 25
élèves et qu'il y en a plus que 20 dans
certaines écoles rurales savoir que les
coûts sont à peu près fixes il y a pas
de division mais ça renchérit la
participation
eu finalement à d'école privée et du
coup si la commune veut faire
l'effort d'investir davantage pour la
rendre attractive et compétitive et bien
ils ont une double peine en étant obligé
encore de payer davantage qu' privé donc
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas revoir un
petit peu le mode de calcul sur les
places disponibles dans une école plutôt
que les places
effectivement occupé samanta
quebon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre d'abord vous
féliciter pour vos prises de positions
courageuse en cette rentrée et bien sûr
votre nomination j'aborderai trois
points euh qui concerne les plus de
400000 élèves des écoles françaises à
l'étranger mais avant je tenais à
envoyer nos pensées à nos communautés
scolaires des lycées français de de Tel
Aviv et de
Jérusalem je tiens aussi à vous
remercier pour votre engagement sans
équivoque contre le harcèlement scolaire
vous avez envoyé des messages de soutien
fort aux victimes et à leur famill
amille qui reprennent espoir de voir la
peur changer de camp et il me demande de
vous le faire savoir si nous sommes
encore au début d'un changement
d'ampleur je souhaitais évoquer avec
vous la mise en place de ce dispositif
prévu sur le territoire national et sa
transposition au aux élèves des lycées
français de l'étranger il existe cert
des dispositifs de lutte contre le
harcèlement dans un certain nombre de
nos établissements français à l'étranger
mais il reste encore beaucoup à faire
dans la mise en œuvre et dans la
formation de tous les personnels des
élèves et des
parents nous devons en effet aller
encore plus loin pour accompagner ses
élèves et ses familles victimes qui
doivent parfois sortir du système
français sans autre alternative que de
rentrer en France ou de s'inscrire dans
un système scolaire étranger donc ma
première question et n'aurions-nous pas
intérêt à coordonner nos forces avec
l'Inspection générale du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale la médiatrice de
l'éducation nationale la EFE l'agence
d'enseignement français à l'étranger et
les opérateurs d'enseignement français
sous la tutelle du ministère des
Affaires étrangères pour transposer ces
dispositifs nationaux au réseau français
de l'étranger deuxième point vous
rappeler également que nous pouvons être
fiers que depuis 2020 des familles
françaises dont les enfants sont en
situation de handicap et scolarisé au
sein du réseau de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger bénéficie
désormais d'une bourse pour le
financement des aesh ainsi plus de
283 élèves à cette rentrée sont
accompagnés financièrement et ce depuis
3 ans maintenant si nous sommes heureux
que ce dispositif se développe au sein
du réseau je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur le fait qu'il faut dès à
présent prévoir de nouveaux moyens en
formation des personnels qui sont
souvent des personnels de droit local et
qui peuvent parfois manquer de
connaissance du système pédagogique
français peut-être que ce point monsieur
le ministre mériterait dès à présent un
diagnostic de l'inspection générale afin
de pouvoir accompagner au mieux ce
dispositif qui monte fortement en
puissance au sein de notre réseau et
enfin dernier point le décret de 2000 19
de l'enseignement français toujours à
l'étranger prévoit un détachement de 2
xis 3 ans des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale en contrepartie de leur retour
en France il avait été pris l'engagement
de les accompagner au retour de
construire un parcours professionnel
avec eux pour valoriser leur acquis
d'expérience afin qu'ils puissent
bénéficier d'une valorisation de leur
parcours à l'étranger malheureusement
aujourd'hui encore on ne reconnais pas
suffisamment ces personnels qui
maîtrisent des langues des bivalences
parfois des parcours de for ateur les
consultations d'avril dernier sur
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
mené par le ministère des Affaires
étrangères et votre ministère et
particulièrement l'atelier encadré par
l'Inspection générale et les ressources
humaines ont commencé à recenser des
propositions faites par les personnels
et les équipes de direction et bien sûr
votre administration pourriez-vous nous
dire si un groupe de travail va être
ouvert au niveau des ressources humaines
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
car les détachés relevant du décret de
2019 dev ont en fin d'année scolaire
2024 préparer leur retour nous ne
pouvons pas les laisser donc sans une
reconnaissance de leur parcours et de
leur engagement d'autant que vous le
savez nous accueillons aujourd'hui près
de 400000 élèves dans 580 établissements
et ce donc correspond à plus de 30000
élèves depuis le lancement de cap 2030
voulu par le le président de la
République et qu'ils ont contribué eux
aussi à l'effort pour atteindre cet
objectif et en voilà emic
Durox
h monsieur le monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président merci de me donner
la parole euh beaucoup de choses ont été
dites je vais essayer d'être quelque peu
concis je vais parler du problème
d'attractivité de notre métier je dis
notre métier parce qu'il y a encore de
semaines j'étais professeur d'histoire-
géographie juste avant mon mon élection
un sujet que que je connais bien euh on
pourrait résumer la situation en disant
qu'aujourd'hui de moins en moins
d'étudiants contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit veulent devenir professeurs et
de plus en plus de professeurs quittent
le métier je voudrais citer ce chiffre
75 % des ruptures conventionnelles dans
la fonction publique concernent des
agents de votre ministère alors que ces
derniers ne représentent que 64 % des
agents de la fonction publique
eu il y a un problème de rémunération je
vais ça a été dit je vais je vais être
assez assez concis je je vais je vais
prendre mon cas personnel j'étais
échelon 7 jusqu'à donc 2 semaines et en
tant qu'échelon 7 j'allais gagner en
effet environ 145 € en plus par mois
mais à l'échelon 8 mes collègues
n'allaient gagner que 80 € en plus euh
pour mon cas personnel toujours je suis
très transparent avec vous j'allais
gagner environ j'allais passer de 2200 €
par mois à 2350 € ce qui au bout de 10
ans d'expérience surtout en région
parenzienne vous en conviendrait est
assez peu et ceci sans 13e mois sans
tickets resto sans médecine du travail
sans comité d'entreprise je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi alors que nous pesons 1
million de fonctionnaires on nétait pas
capable de faire en sorte que les
professeurs qui ont certes beaucoup de
vacances mais qui sont finalement
incapables d'en prendre parce qu'ils ont
pas les moyens de partir plus d'une
semaine n'avent pas des des des des prix
négociés alors que nous représente
représentons une force de frappe très
conséquente he donc on a 4 mois de
vacances mais on peut partir qu'une
semaine
eu donc je je pense que de ce point de
vue-là il y a des choses à travailler
pour renforcer l'attractivité et donc
ma question au-delà des des
revalorisations qui en plus ne rattrape
pas le pouvoir d'achat perdu en 30 ans
qui ont été largement reniés par
l'inflation et qui en plus pour la
plupart d'entre elles sont sous forme
d'indemnité qui ne compte pas pour la
retraite et bien je voulais savoir si et
bien vous aviez des pistes pour
améliorer concrètement la situation
matérielle de beaucoup d'enseignants des
800000 enseignants de France je vous
remercie voilà évidemment il y a
plusieurs thèmes qui se recouvent je
vais vous laisser répondre et regrouper
peut-être les les réponses ou merci il y
a plusieurs effectivement interventions
qui ont repris des thèmes comparable et
donc je vais tâcher d'y répondre de la
manière la plus
exhaustive possible d'abord
peut-être démarrer sur la question de la
rentrée scolaire évidemment on a eu
l'occasion de le dire l'objectif qui a
été fixé c'est que tous les postes
soient pourvus pour la rentrée scolaire
en l'occurrence quand on a fait le
dernier point à la mi-septembre la fin
septembre on é à 99,95 % de postes
pourvu ce à quoi vous faites référence
madame la sénatrice ça n'est pas des
postes que nous n'avons pas été capable
de pourvoir ce sont des postes qui ont
été pourvus mais dont les enseignants
qui avaient pourvu ces postes étaient
absents donc quand vous parlez de chaise
vide c'est en réalité des enseignants
que vous visez qui ont été absents moi
je suis pas dans le fonctionnaire
baching ou dans le enseignant baching
donc je je ne partage pas les propos que
vous avez tenus c'est des enseignants
qui étaient absents mais qui étaient
affecté sur un poste donc l'objectif
c'est précisément de pouvoir assurer le
remplacement quand il y a des absences
et c'est l'un des enjeu du pacte
enseignant alors vous dites c'est des
missions supplémentaires il y a déjà
beaucoup d'enseignants qui font du
remplacement de courte durée avec des
heures supplémentaires en moyenne 2 heur
par semaine donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
déjà une réalité dans nos établissements
simplement là ils seront mieux rémunérés
ça passe de 40 € à 70 € de l'heure donc
c'est du plus pour ces enseignants qui
s'engagent euh qui s'engagent euh
davantage je vais insister sur le fait
puisque vous avez dit j'insiste sur le
besoin d'enseignant qualifié vous avez
insisté plusieurs fois sur qualifi je
pense que c'était peut-être une
référence au contractuel moi je veux
remercier et saluer les enseignants et
contractuels qui sont auprès de nos
élèves c'est 5 % de nos enseignants
finidalement notre objectif c'est
d'avoir le plus de titulaires possible
mais je veux rappeler que 90 % d'entre
eux enseigna déjà l'année dernière et
ils ont acquis en cela une expérience
mais évidemment notre objectif c'est qui
puisse être être titularisé sur la
question des contrats non signés ou
salaires non versés effectivement on a
eu un certain nombre d'alertes notamment
à Mayotte sur des contractuels mayott
qui connaît d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
et bien d'autres difficultés sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir si vous le
souhaitez mais également dans le
valdoise où il y a un certain nombre de
dossiers notamment d'aesh qui ont dû
être repris à la
main ce qui a entraîné effectivement des
délais donc la consigne que j'ai donné à
l'ensemble des rectorats c'est de verser
immédiatement des accomtes de manière
qu'on se retrouve pas ou jusqu'à 90 % de
manière à ce qu'on se retrouve pas avec
effectivement des personnels qui ne
n'ont pas de rémunération pendant un
certain temps on agit pour régler ces
ces ces situations sur la rémunération
des enseignants je veux vraiment pour le
coup là me permettre de corriger ce que
je ne fais pas souvent mais ce que vous
avez dit contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit dans le calcul qui est fait
pour dire qu'entre septembre 2022 et
septembre 2023 tous les enseignant gagne
entre 125 et 250 € net de plus il n'y a
pas la prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat dans ce calcul elle n'en fait
pas partie il y a effectivement la
revalorisation du point d'indice qui en
fait partie celle qui a eu lieu cet été
qui concerne tout le monde enfin les
syndicats enseignants demandaient aussi
cette revalorisation du point d'indice
donc ça me semble normal qu'on l'intègre
dedans il faut se rendre compte quand
même du chemin parcouru un enseignant en
début de carrière né au tiulaire il y a
3 ans il gagnait 1700 € net par mois on
est à 2100 € net par mois c'est 400 € de
plus en 3 ans alors j'entends he que
évidemment il faut que ça continue à
augmenter j'entends parfaitement ces
demande enfin faut aussi reconnaître et
mesurer le chemin qui a été parcouru
dans une administration qui compte
860000 enseignants donc évidemment dès
que vous prenez une mesure de
revalorisation tout de suite c'est des
des sommes budgétaires très importantes
je suis bien placé pour le savoir
j'étais de l'autre côté de la scène à
quand ces décisions ont ont été
prises sur ensuite la question sur les
maths on n'est pas du tout au bout de ce
qu'il faut faire pour redresser le
niveau en mathématique dans notre pays
pas du tout mais c'éit d'abord très
important de rétablir lire les maths
dans le Tron commun en première comme on
le fait en cette rentrée mais on n'est
pas au bout il faut continuer à agir
dans le premier degré collège peut-être
au lycée on verra j'attends de voir les
propositions qui me seront faites par la
Mission exigence des savoirs que j'ai
engagé ah oui madame mon j'ai oublié de
vous répondre vous disiez 8 semaines
c'est très court pour agir en même temps
sur cette question de l'élévation du
niveau il y a honnêtement énormément de
rapport d'audit d'avis de proposition y
compris de parlementaires de sénateurs
du conseil scientifique de l'éducation
nationale de l'inspection générale je
pense que maintenant il est peut-être
temps de concrétiser tout ça donc la
mission que j'ai installé hier elle vise
à s'appuyer aussi sur cette somme de
rapports et de travaux qui ont été remis
ces dernières années pour faire des
propositions opérationnelles donc oui on
aura la possibilité d'avancer rapidement
et je vais vous le dire on le doit à nos
élèves on le doit à nos élèves de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
élever le niveau donc sur les maths on
va continuer j'ai ouvert un certain
nombre de pistes dans mon intervention à
la BNF de la semaine dernière notamment
pour élever le niveau le fait peut-être
de fonctionner au moins sur le français
et les mathématiques par des groupes de
compétences au collège je pense que
c'est une piste intéressante à la fin et
ça c'est des enseignants eux-mêmes qui
me le disent quand vous avez des élèves
qui ont un niveau tellement différent
sur les mathématiques ou sur le français
dans une même classe vous finissez par
tirer tout le monde vers le bas parce
que ceux qui ont le niveau ne peuvent
plus progresser et les autres n'arrivent
pas à progresser donc moi j'assume de
dire que sur le français et les
mathématiques c'est une piste ça se
regarde c'est pas là une annonce que je
suis en train de faire mais en tout cas
je souhaite que la mission puisse y
travailler expertiser s'il ne serait pas
opportun de penser une organisation sur
le français et les mathématiqu par
groupe de compétenence au
collège je pose la question non non non
attention je suis pas en train de dire
non je suis pas en train de dire qu'on
revient sur le collège unique je suis
pas en train de dire
non je ne suis pas en train de dire je
ne suis pas en train de dire non non je
ne suis pas en train de dire même que je
suis pour le retour des classes de
niveau moi je suis pour qu'on continue à
avoir un groupe classe avec des élèves
très différents ce que je dis mais vous
savez en fait déjà des 7 rentrées on
commence à le faire puisque pour l'heure
supplémentaire dont tu as parlé Madame
De Marco à la place de l'heure de
technologie en français en mathématique
on fonctionne par groupe de compétences
puisque sur cette heure supplémentaire
de français mathématique de soutien
approfondissement oui c'est sur une
heure ce que je veux dire c'est voilà ça
pas ENF voilà on est toujours dans le
collège unique je dis simplement que la
question se pose si on veut faire
progresser tout le monde de savoir s'il
faut garder des élèves avec un niveau
aussi hétérogène et ce qui par ailleurs
permettrait aussi peut-être pour des
élèves qui en ont le plus besoin d'avoir
des plus petits groupes dans ces
disciplines et pour des élèves dont on
voit que ils ont des compétences à un
niveau qui leur permet d'avancer plus
rapidement d'avoir des groupes plus
importants vous savez un syndicat un
syndicat enseignant le snalk pour ne pas
le citer avait fait une proposition il y
a quelques années de collège modulaire
j'ai demandé à la mission de regarder ce
sujet-là je vois que ça déchaîne les
passions ici au Sénat donc je suis ravi
je me réjouis de revenir en parler avec
vous quand on prendra des
décisions alors laissez finir le
ministre ensuite c'est aussi mon
bisutage j'imagine pour cette première
audition euh sur l'école inclusive sujet
absolument majeur euh oui il y a un
manque de place en im et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à mes collègues
horuror berger et Fadila catabi elles se
sont engagé auprès de moi à ce qu'on
avance sur ce
sujet-là la réalité c'est que sur
l'école inclusive on a fait d'énormes
progrès quantitatifs en terme de nombre
d'élèves accueillis depuis
2017 plus de 100000 élèves de plus qui
sont accueillis parce qu'on a créé 40000
postes d'ESH on est en train de
décécariser ce métier avec plus de 50 %
qui sont en CDI des revalorisations même
s'il faut continuer à agir sur le temps
de travail je le disais tout à l'heure
maintenant il faut qu'on avance vers du
qualitatif et moi j'avoue je suis frappé
par beaucoup d'enseignants professeurs
des écoles notamment que je renc compte
qui me disent qu'ils se sentent parfois
dépassés euh et c'est un peu ce que vous
avez dit dans votre intervention donc il
y a la transformation à venir des piales
en passe moi je pense que c'est une
bonne piste parce que ça serait un point
d'entrée unique pour les familles pour
les accompagn y compris dans leur
démarche avec la MDPH aujourd'hui les
piales c'est essentiellement ça ça gère
essentiellement entre guillemets
administrativement les aesh là l'idée
c'est aussi qu'à travers ses passes on
puisse à faire intervenir des personnels
du médico-social auprès des enseignants
et des professeurs des écooles autre
sujet il faut qu'on renforce aussi les
heures de euh scolarité dans les
établissements médicaux-sociaux parce
que la réalité c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui parfois des familles pour
qui la MDPH prescrit euh un une une
place un accueil en établissement
médico-social en IME ou en ITEP et la
famille elle-même souhaite que l'enfant
puisse aller à l'école parce qu'il y a
plus d'heures de cours donc il faut
qu'on arrive aussi à avoir davantage de
scolarité dans ses établissements
médicaux-sociaux parfois vous avez des
familles pour qui ont prescrit une place
en IME ou en ITEP qui souhaitent mettre
leurs enfants leur enfant dans un
établissement médico-social mais qui
faute de place ne le peuvent pas et donc
effectivement il va à l'école qu'on soit
clair l'objectif c'est que l'objectif
c'est que on ait le meilleur
accompagnement possible pour tous les
élèves tous les élèves et tous les
enfants de la République quelle que soit
leur situation le handicap ont le droit
à être scolarisé dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour eux parfois ça
passe le plus souvent ça passe par
l'école euh en milieu ordinaire avec un
accompagnement une adaptation parfois ça
passe par une place en établissement
médico-social dans lequel il doit y
avoir de l'école j'insiste aussi sur la
mission qui a été confiée au président
du département de la Somme monsieur
auossoulier et à Lucy Carasco très
engagée sur les questions de handicap
justement sur le rapprochement entre ime
enfin établissements médicaux-sociaux et
écoles mais je le dis je suis ce sujetlà
est important pour moi parce que je ne
voudrais pas que certains cherchent à
instrumentaliser ces situations
difficiles sur le terrain pour essayer
de nous faire revenir sur l'école
inclusive y compris euh une
instrumentalisation politique j'ai
observé peut-être comme un certain
nombre d'entre vous que l'extrême droite
allemande lafd euh il y a quelques mois
annoncé qu'elle mettait désormais au
cœur de son projet politique le rejet de
l'école inclusive et j'ai observé que en
France lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle un candidat euh a
commencé à toucher du doigt ce sujet-là
moi je ne veux pas qu'on revienne sur ce
progrès quand même qui est l'accueil des
élèves en situation de handicap euh à
l'école et donc il faut qu'on soit
capable de répondre aujourd'hui aux
préoccupations qui sont exprimées par
les famille par les élèves et par les
professeurs des écoles désolé je suis un
peu long mais ça me semble être un sujet
qui le mérite et qui le justifie sur le
harcèlement évidemment on va regardz le
cas que vous évoquez quand on dit c'est
à l'élève harceleur de changer
d'établissement et pas l'élève harcelé
d'abord il faut que ça arrive en fin de
de de course entre guillemets c'estàdire
que avant il faut tout faire pour régler
la situation sans avoir à en arriver là
notamment dans le premier degré mais
enfin c'est important qu'il puisse y
avoir cette sanction si on règle pas la
situation de si effectivement les élèves
eux-mêmes après après qu'on est exploré
avec toutes les propositions souhaitent
eux-mêmes changer il faut qu'ils
puissent le faire mais il faut d'abord
que il a conscience et qu'on leur donne
toutes les conditions pour qu'ils se
disent qu'ils ont le choix et donc sur
ce sujet on va regarder la situation que
vous évoquez de manière évidemment très
importante sur monsieur la vous avez
parlé donc sur les mathématiques j'ai
répondu sur la qualité éducative dans le
monde rural et plusieurs sont intervenus
sur sur ce sujet là oui il faut donner
de la visibilité pluriannuelle pour le
coup on peut beaucoup plus le faire en
milieu rural qu'en milieu urbain euh il
faut donner cette visibilité
pluriannuelle c'est un engagement qui a
été pris par la première ministre dans
le cadre de France ruralité il y a
maintenant une instance au niveau
départemental avec les services dsdenen
et les élus locaux pour donner cette
visibilité sur 3 ans et donc voilà il
faut maintenant que cette instance se
metent en place qu'elle fonctionne bien
et qu'elle puisse donner cette
visibilité je suivrai de très près sa
mise en œuvre sur la question de
l'attractivité là aussi plusieurs
d'entre vous en ont parlé donc je vais
répondre en répondant à Monsieur LEC oui
c'est un enjeu absolument majeur j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire comment est-ce
qu'on retrouve l'attractivité la
question des salaires j'ai l'occasion de
dire ce qu'on a engagé ce qu'on a fait
il a la question de la formation
initiale là aussi j'ai répondu il y a la
question du déroulement de la carrière
la progression de carrière on voit dans
un certain nombre d'études et d'ailleurs
dans certain nombre d'échanges avec les
organisations syndicales ou des
enseignants qu'au milieu de la carrière
il y a probablement en terme de
progression à la fois
salarial mais aussi d'opportunités qui
peuvent être offertes quelque chose à
faire il y a un sujet aussi je pense de
capacité pour l'administration éducation
nationale à permettre aux enseignants
d'identifier de valoriser et de
certifier les compétences acquises par
l'enseignement aujourd'hui vous échangez
avec des jeunes vous en trouvez assez
peu qui vous disent qu'il se voi faire
le même métier toute leur vie ils le
disent souvent j'aurais 1000 vie dans ma
vie et mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il en
serait différemment pour l'éducation
nationale évidemment si des jeunes
soitent souhait d vevenir enseignant et
souhaite l'être toute leur vie on sera
les premiers ravis et on fera tout pour
qu'ils aient envie d'y rester mais il
faut pas qu'on renvoie l'idée à ces
jeunes
candidats que c'est qui ne pourront pas
faire autre chose s'ils en ont envie un
moment dans leur vie et d'ailleurs quand
vous échangez avec des employeurs privés
ou publics ils vous disent qu'a priori
quelqu'un qui a géré une classe au
hasard de collège pendant 15 ans en
terme de résilience de capacité à
s'adapter de compétences qui ont été
acquise évidemment qu'il a beaucoup de
choses à à valoriser s'il veut faire
autre chose donc je pense qu'il faut
aussi qu'on soit capable d'avoir cette
rénovation de l'animation de carrière de
la valorisation des carrières pour les
enseignants qui le souhaiteraient ça
sera aussi un des éléments de
l'attractivité et enfin il y a un sujet
qui est majeur et là j'ai vu que vous
aviez fait des propositions donc on va
regarder on en parle avec les syndicats
qui est celui des affectations et
mutations évidemment que c'est un frein
pour certains et que vous avez même
certains candidats qui se disent bah je
préfère ne pas être titulaire et passer
le conours être contractuel pour pouvoir
rester dans mon académie donc après donc
moi je suis pragmatique lucide je pense
que si un système parfait qui contentait
tout le monde existait j'ose espérer que
certains de mes prédécesseurs l'auraient
trouvé ou identifier mais pas sûr
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas il ne
connaissaiit pas le Sénat et donc on va
regarder votre proposition et on va on y
travaille avec les organisations
syndicale si on arrive à trouver par
exemple un système qui permet de dire à
un enseignant si vous acceptez telle
mutation telle affectation on vous donne
la garantie qu'au bout de 3 ans ou 5 ans
vous aurez un retour dans votre académie
d'origine avec la possibilité de choisir
peut-être que ça permettra de faciliter
les choses donc il faut que ce système
soit faisable qu'il existe ça fait
partie à la fois de ce qu'on discute
dans la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales sur
l'attractivité et j'ai aussi missionné
le Conseil scientifique de l'éducation
nationale pour qu'il me fasse une
proposition sur le sujet évidemment tous
ces travaux s'appuieront aussi sur les
propositions que vous avez faites euh
mais comme quoi encore une fois madame
Monier il y a a plein de rapports qui
existent de proposition donc maintenant
on peut
avancer excusez-mo monsieur ministre je
crois que c'est dans la PPL de Max
Brisson donc et dans et dans le rapport
sur le métier d'enseignant qu'on avait
livré avec Françoise la bord il y a déjà
quelques quelques années de 3 ans sur le
contrat me semble être une bonne réponse
donc on regardera évidemment cette cette
proposition euh monsieur
Brisson sur la laïcité
euh vous avez vous l'avez dit j'étais ce
matin avec Gérald
dararmmanin dans une école juive de de
sarcell pour réaffirmer évidemment la
promesse de la République qui est la
protection de tous ces enfants il soit
scolarisé à l'école publique ou dans une
école privée école
confessionnelle ce que nous avons eu
l'occasion de rappeler c'est qu'il y a
un déploiement très important de force
de sécurité je veux leur rendre hommage
pour sécuriser d'une manière générale
les établissements de confession juives
mais en particulier les écoles avec une
présence de policiers statique devant
les établissements ça c'est absolument
majeur ça a été redit ce matin par le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et je remercie
le ministre de l'Intérieur et les
services de son ministère pour la
sécurité qui a ainsi apporté à ses
élèves évidemment je je comprends la la
préoccupation des familles et leurs
inquiétudes et c'est notre
responsabilité qu'être au rendez-vous
avec les moyens nécessaires ils sont là
ensuite vous avez abordé un autre sujet
absolument majeur qui est la sécurité
des élèves de confession juives dans
l'école publique
qui est un sujet qui ne date pas de ce
conflit on le sait il y a des agressions
euh de
l'antisémitisme qui se déploie depuis
des années dans nos établissements dans
des établissements
scolaires dont sont victimes des élèves
de confession juivees et un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs vu
leur famille faire le choix de les
scolariser dans le privé pour ces
raisonslà on a eu ces dernières heures
et ces derniers jours plusieurs alertes
qui qui sont remonté d'agression
d'intimidation qui ont eu lieu dans des
établissements s'appuyant sur la
situation internationale pour intimider
ou menacer des élèves de confession juiv
je le dis c'est absolument inadmissible
et on sera intraitable j'ai demandé hier
qu'il y ait césine d'abord j'ai demandé
hier que systématiquement quand il y a
des faits de cette nature ça remonte au
ministère
systématiquement deuxièmement j'ai
demandé qu'il y ait systématiquement
saisine du procureur de la République
qu'il ait plainte ou qu' n'y ait pas
plainte le ministère saisira le
procureur de la République et pour avoir
échangé avec mon collègue Éric Dupont
Moretti et mon collègue Gérald d'Anin je
peux vous dire que la réactivité à la
fois de la police et de la justice
seront au rendez-vous j'ai l'occasion de
montrer sur un autre sujet qui est celui
du harcèlement qu' après avoir appelé un
électrochoc on avait une réactivité très
forte aussi de nos forces de sécurité et
évidemment des sanctions disciplinaires
à l'endroit des élèves donc je passe le
message de manière très claire je l'ai
fait ce matin des élèves qui
intimideraient menaceraient
agresseraient ou envisagerait de le
faire des camarades des élèves de
confession juives devrait avoir peur il
aurait de bonnes raisons d'avoir peur
parce qu'on sera intraitable dans la
réponse qu'on apportera sur la deuxième
question que vous avez évoqué sur la
neutralité religieuse des
accompagnateurs de sortie
scolaire c'est un sujet je dois le dire
qui m'a beaucoup fait réfléchir parce
que d'un côté vous avez raison c'est ils
accompagnent une activité qui se déroule
dans un on va dire un cadre scolaire
puisque c'est des élèves qui vont en
sortie scolaire en même temps ils ne
sont pas dans
l'école et je sais que ça posé question
à beaucoup de monde ce qui a fini par me
convaincre c'est une tribune que j'ai lu
dans la presse qui date il y a quelques
années mais qui reste d'actualité je
vous en lis un extrait la tribune
s'appelle pour le droit des MRES voilés
à accompagner les sorties scolaires je
vous lis le le résumé je ne pense pas
qu'il faille réglementer la tenue des
parents d'élèves comme celle des élèves
autant la loi de mars 2004 était tout à
fait nécessaire pour sortir du cas par
cas et sanctuariser l'intérieur de
l'école autant il faut savoir faire
preuve de souplesse quand il s'agit de
parents et des sorties scolaires pour
une raison simple qui tient à une
certaine idée de la laïcité mais aussi
de l'école publique cette tribune elle a
été signée par Caroline Fourest qu'on ne
peut pas accuser a priori d'être dans la
relativisation de la laïcité que ce soit
à l'école ou dans la société et je vous
invite à lire ce texte qui est c'est sur
le H po c'est ce texte qui a achevé de
me convaincre donc autant j'ai une
détermination absolue et j'assume
toement la décision que j'ai prise sur
l'application de la loi 2004 dans
l'école de la République qui a été
validée par le Conseil d'État qui s'est
prononcé sur le fond autant sur ce
sujet-l j'assume aussi la décision qui
est qui est la mienne qui est de ne pas
revenir sur les règles actuellement en
vigueur j'entends que ça puisse faire
débat qui des propositions différentes
qui viennent de groupes politiques mais
j'assume ma décision sur l'école sur le
Conseil des Sages évidemment j'ai
l'occasion de rencontrer dès ma
nomination la présidente Dominique
Schnapper évidemment le Conseil d'État
sera rétabli dans toutes ses
prérogatives et son fonctionnement euh
même si je pense qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre de malentendu parce que je crois
pas qu'il a été qu'il a eu des volontés
de mon prédécesseur d'empêcher le
Conseil des Sages de de travailler
convenablement évidemment euh mais en
tout cas j'ai vu la présidente Dominique
Schnapper et je lui ai dit qu'évidemment
le Conseil pouvait s'autoaisir dès qu'il
le souhaitait et que le cœur de son
travail c'était l'application de la
laïcité euh dans l'éducation nationale
donc là de ce point de vue-là je vous
rassure j'ai répondu sur école rurale
sur école normale ça fait partie du
débat que j'aurai avec ma collègue de
l'enseignement supérieur on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter elle est quand
même très concernée comme vous avez vous
l'avez sous-entendu dans votre
intervention sur le lien entre la
formation des maîtres et l'université
c'est un beau débat c'est un débat
nécessaire j'entends un certain nombre
de vos arguments d'autres me posent
davantage questions je pense que c'est
important qu'on ait cette réflexion on
l'URA avec les organisations syndicales
et au sein du gouvernement évidemment
avec les les universités
euh madame de La provoté on me dit mon
équipe me dit que je suis trop long dans
mes réponses il y a beaucoup
d'interventions madame de La provoté sur
le S sur le 100 % e je vais regarder les
alertes que vous avez formulé sur
l'impact sur un certain nombre d'acteurs
évidemment l'objectif c'est de renforcer
l'accès de nos élèves à la pratique
artistique et et à la découverte
culturelle et à l'éducation artistique
et culturelle donc on va
évidemment regarder les effets de bord
éventuels que vous avez évoqué sur le
bilan qu'on peut faire du passculture
collectif euh à
l'école je pense que c'est très utile
parce que ça permet de donner un budget
pour réaliser des activités culturelles
pour les élèves je pense que ça mérite
c'est un dispositif qui mérite d'être
davantage mis en avant je me rends
compte qu'il y a beaucoup d'équipes
encore sur le terrain qui connaissent
pas forcément l'existence de ce
dispositif c'est quand même 25 € par an
par élève c'est ça pour faire des
activités donc voilà je pense qu'il faut
qu'on après il est probablement
perfectible donc on va y travailler
aussi euh j'ai vraiment de grandes
ambitions aussi sur ce sujet j'ai
l'occasion de le dire la culture
générale à l'école et notamment de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle je
pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
notamment dans le premier degré euh sur
la question des élèves scolarisés dans
les écoles euh hors contrat il y a
aujourd'hui environ 1900 écoles hors
contrat les 2/ers des élèves scolarisés
ne sont dans le 1er degré et un/ers dans
le second degré vous savez que dans le
quinena précédent il y a un un nouveau
cadre juridique qui a été mis en place
euh pour mettre en œuvre ce nouveau
cadre juridique le nombre de contrôles a
très fortement augmenté on est passé de
174 contrôles au cours de l'année
scolaire
2013-2014 à 668 pour l'année
20212022 les services veillent à ce
qu'aucun établissement ne puisse ouvrir
sans avoir été déclaré ou ou avant la
fin du délai d'opposition il y a un
suivi évidemment extrêmement extrêmement
fort sur la question euh de l'empathie
euh oui j'assume de dire je sais pas si
empathie est le meilleur terme euh
l'altruisme le rapport à l'autre à la
différence à la tolérance la
bienveillance bref euh qu'on finalement
qu'on réponde à cette ambition de
Rousseau qui disait qu'on doit à la fois
instruire l'esprit et éduquer le cœur et
je pense que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité et quand on regarde les
pays qui ont réussi à faire reculer
massivement le harcèlement scolaire
c'est des pays qui ont massivement
investi aussi sur ces enjeux-là dès les
premières classes jeis allé au Danemark
mais il y a d'autres exemples il y a par
ailleurs des initiatives qui existent et
qui nous montrent àel point c'est utile
alors il y a la méthode danoise qui est
d'ailleurs déployée dans des écoles à
saint-toin ou à Paris grâce au rectorat
de Paris notamment qui s'est beaucoup
engagé sur ce sujet-là il y a des
établissements qui appliquent d'autres
méthodes je pense notamment à ce qui est
porté par le philosophe frééric Lenoir
et la Fondation sè les ateliers philo
ateli à Visé philosophique en primaire
moi je crois beaucoup à toutes ces
initiatives donc comment on va faire
l'objectif et j'ai saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes c'est d'avoir
un programme sur le sujet pour le
premier degré à la rentrée prochaine
2024 et dès la rentrée janvier 2024
après les vacances qu'on est au moins
dans chaque département au moins une
école qui expérimente ces temps
d'apprentissage du rapport à l'autre du
respect de l'autre de l'empathie sur
l'ORD de technoon voilà c'est ce qui a
permis s'agit décision de mon
prédécesseur de ne pas surcharger le
l'agenda des l'emploi du temps des
élèves et donc pour avoir cette heure
supplémentaire de soutien
approfondissement en math français la
mettre à la place de l'heure de
technologie bon c'est un choix qui a été
fait évidemment ça veut pas dire qu'on
renonce à nos ambitions sur la
découverte de la technologie et sur
l'apprentissage de cette discipline qui
est absolument essentielle y compris
pour être capable de comprendre les
enjeux aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence
artificielle et autres mais c'est pour
ça qu'on raisonne aussi par cycle et que
avant la 6e il y a déjà des initiations
qui sont mis en place évidemment après
il y a aussi a beaucoup de choses qui
sont mises en place et qu'on veut
continuer à investir sur
sur ce
sujet monsieur fialer je regarderai
évidemment la mission d'information qui
avait le rapport qui avait été remis sur
la culture citoyenne mais le président
du Conseil supérieur des programmes m'a
dit que l'équipe qui travaille sur les
propositions en matière de de de MC
s'appuya aussi sur les travaux
parlementaires donc je pense qu'il
s'appuieront sur ces travaux sur la
question effectivement augmentation de
la participation école privée j'ai eu
plusieurs saisines sur le sujet et donc
il faut qu'on a une réunion de travail
qu'on échange à la fois avec avec les
associations d'élus et évidemment les
représentants de l'enseignement privé
pour regarder comment est-ce qu'on peut
répondre à ces à ces à ces
préoccupations qui sont exprimées mais
je les ai entendu sur Madame casbonne
sur le déploiement du plan du plan
harcèlement évidemment ça va nécessiter
une mobilisation de tous et partout et
je remercie aussi les sénateurs qui se
sont engagés sur le sujet j'avais reçu
Colette Méo qui n'est plus je crois se
représentait pas mais qui avait fait un
rapport un très bon rapport sur le sujet
aussi et on s'est appuyé aussi sur ces
travaux pour avancer l'objectif c'est
d'aller du vers le 100 % prévention 100
% détection et 100 % réaction pour face
au harcèlement je vais pas revenir sur
le contenu du plan évidemment j'aurais à
cœur qu'il puisse se déployer aussi dans
les établissements français à l'étranger
mais qui je dois le dire d'ailleurs
souvent sont aussi un peu laboratoire
sur des dispositifs hein sur sur la
question du harcèlement ou sur d'autres
je me suis rendu au au Danemark je le
disais où je suis allé dans au lycée
français voilà ils avaient déployé des
initiatives donc voilà je j'essaie de
d'avancer plus rapidement pardon sur la
formation des
aesh dans le réseau des de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger à
l'étranger c'est en grande majorité la
famille qui emploie les aesh cependant
le recrutement peut se faire en
collaboration avec l'établissement le
financement des aesh dans les établiss
ement du réseau français à l'étranger ne
relève pas de l'éducation nationale mais
les familles françaises ou binationales
qui recrutent et rémunè un ou une àes
peuvent recevoir de la part de la EFE
une aide financière spécifique et c'est
le ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères qui assû la tutelle vous le
savez sur la EFE demeurant on peut
réfléchir je pense effectivement avec le
ministère des Affaires étrangères et la
EFE a des actions de formation en
direction de ses personnels c'est
absolument nécessaire et là je pense
qu'on on peut s'appuyer aussi sur des
choses qui ont été engagées pour
progresser en la matière pardon j'ai été
très long non c'était important le
zonage deéducation
prioritaire sera-t-il revu ou pas
c'était Sonia de la probuté j'ai oublié
zonage éducation prioritaire oui à un
moment donné il sera revu la question
c'est quand j'ai conscience que beaucoup
plusieurs de mes prédécesseurs vous ont
fait cette même réponse avant moi mais
là on approche je pense notamment parce
que l'objectif c'est aussi qu'il y ait
une cohérence avec la nouvelle carte des
qpv qui doit intervenir prochainement
puisque vous savez que la cartographie
des cartes quartier politique de la
ville interviendra bientôt et je pense
que c'est important qu'on puisse faire
le travail en cohérence ensemble si on
appliquait aujourd'hui les critères
actuelle de l'éducation enfin de la
cartographie actuelle et qu'on disait on
fait une actualisation sans ne rien
toucher au critèr il y a 200
établissements qui rentreraient en
éducation prioritaire et 200
établissements qui en sortiraiement
c'est beaucoup plus simple d'en faire
rentrer que d'en sortir avec l'Impact
qu'on connaît d'autant qu'on a
énormément réinvesti dans l'éducation
prioritaire donc il y a un enjeu à la
fois d'interrogation sur les critères
qui permettent de relever de l'éducation
prioritaire et sûr dans le cas où des
établissements sortirait la manière dont
on accompagne cette transition mais
voilà c'est un sujet sur lequel je vais
avancer dans les prochains mois je dis
pas que la cartographie sera actualisée
dans les prochains mois mais en tout cas
je pense qu'à horizon 2024 2025 on aura
avancer sur ce sujet mes chers collègues
vous êtes encore quelques-uns à vouloir
poser des questions je vais vraiment
vous demander parce qu'il est déjà 18h30
passer d'être très rapide dans la euh
dans votre
question pierre ouyas Cédric Vial
Catherine belrti Yann Chantrel Colomb
Brossel adelzian David Ross et Mathilde
olivieras merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Ministre bienvenue à
vous et puis merci de nous consacrer
autant autant de de votre temps juste
une phrase déclarative je je pense
sincèrement que l'école hors les murs
c'est la même chose que l'école dans la
classe et qu'elle doit être encadrée par
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
la question elle est pas vestimentaire
elle est statutaire VO ça c'est mon mon
point de vue moi je voulais vous
questionner sur la mixité sociale des
établissements vous connaissez les haut
scène notre département commun les les
les 10 établissements qu'ont l'indice de
positionnement social le plus élevé sont
tous privés et ceux qu'on l'indice de
positionnement social le plus faible
sont tous publics il y a une forme de de
séparatisme qui se met en place et votre
collègue avait eu le courage de soulever
la question la réponse ça a été une une
convention avec l'enseignement
catholique je crois pas qu'elle puisse
contraindre les établissements à à
changer leur politique et ma question
est est très simple est-ce que est-ce
qu'il est légitime que l'état donne de
l'argent à des établissements privés
sous contrat qui ont fait le choix
économique de choisir des élèves qui
viennent des milieux les plus favorisés
voilà est-ce qu'il est normal qu'on leur
donne autant d'argent que les autres
c'est tout une 1 minute 20 secondes j'ai
le droit un bon point monsieur le
Président je suis pas sûr que la réponse
se fasse en une minute 20 secondes par
contre mais Cédric Vial donc Catherine
Berl alors une d'abord une remarque qui
est remontée de des chefs
d'établissement qui effectivement vous
avez souhaité reconquérir le mois de
juin et proposer donc ce stage de de
semaines Hume pour les élèves de Seconde
alors c'est une très bonne intention
sauf que ça va être extrêmement
difficile à être à mettre en œuvre dans
surtout dans nos régions qui sont des
régions plutôt rurales donc il va
falloir faire attention parce que on
aura beaucoup de soucis pour trouver des
stage à tous les tous les élèves
deuxième chose vous avez parlé vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que c'était pas une
crise de vocation malheureusement salée
et quand on a des enseignants qui
effectivement commencent à enseigner
j'avais jamais vu ça j'ai fait 39 ans
d'enseignement et bien aujourd'hui ils
enseignent pendant un an et ensuite ils
quittent le métier pourquoi parce que
effectivement les élèves deviennent de
plus en plus difficiles mais parce qu'on
a voulu faire des classes de niveau
unique et ça ça ne fonctionne pas je
crois que tout le monde vous l'a fait
remonter je crois qu'il faut songer à
revoir le système alors peut-être pas
pour toutes les classes mais il faudra à
un moment donné qu'il y ait une classe
avec pour les enfants qui ont des
difficultés parce que les enseignants
sont faits pour cela mais qu'il y ait
également une classe d'excellence et on
naurait pas à ce moment-là le problème
qu'a connu ma camarade ma collègue
pardon et qui où on traite les enfants
qui veulent aller plus loin d'un TLO
depuis qu'on a mis en place ce système
et bien on a effectivement les niveaux
qui sont qui ont chuté plutôt que que de
progresser et enfin concernant
l'enseignement de l'éducation civique et
morale donc j'étais professeur
d'histoire moi aussi pendant 39 ans et
je crois qu'on enseigne beaucoup les
droits mais pas assez les devoirs et je
crois que c'est un des premiers
renseignements qu'il faudrait faire en
classe
merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur le ministre ça n'étonnera pas
mes collègues je vais vous interroger
moi sur la la question du du handicap et
et des aesh
euh vous avez déjà un peu évoqué le
sujet donc je vais je vais aller à
l'essentiel vous vous l'avez dit c'est
aujourd'hui plus de 135000 à es c'est
plus de 50 % de moyens supplémentaires
qui ont été mis de depuis 5 ans des
moyens qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
très importants et pourtant cette
augmentation de moyens financiers
humains ne permet pas aujourd'hui de
répondre ni aux attentes des familles ni
à ceux des des enfants ou des élèves et
elle met parfois même l'institution
scolaire et les enseignants en grande
difficulté cette massification de de
l'accompagnement humain sans
modification profonde du système
d'organisation et de gouvernance de de
la part de de l'éducation nationale a
atteind une limite et elle nuit
désormais à une politique qualitative
efficiente de d'inclusion scolaire dans
dans le rapport que que j'ai pu rendre
et que je vous ai transmis cet été que
j'ai fait au nom de la de la commission
de l'éducation
j'ai fait une vingtaine de propositions
en en faisant notamment des mesures
d'accessibilité qui sont du premier
ressort de de de l'école la priorité
accessibilité physique matérielle mais
surtout
pédagogique alors qu'elle n'aurait
jamais dû cesser de de l'être au
détriment de l'accompagnement humain qui
est de la compensation qu'on appelle la
compensation l'accompagnement humain qui
est qui est évidemment importante mais
qui ne peut intervenir qu'en complément
de ces mesures d'accessibilité euh et
donc il nous faut une organisation
administrative corriger une prise en
charge des des enfants en situation de
handicap plus qualitative et surtout
continue je suis très heureux de ce que
vous je vous ai entendu dire tout à
l'heure de dire que finalement le plus
important c'est que chacun soit à sa
place chaque enfant bénéficie du
meilleur accompagnement qui qui est
celui dont il a besoin ce n'est
malheureusement pas le cas aujourd'hui
et c'est probablement ce qui déstabilise
l'ensemble du système donc je reviendrai
pas sur quelques annonces que que vous
avez faites sur les la modification du
pial mais qui pose aussi un certain
nombre de questions et soulève un
certain nombre de craintes autant qu'il
ne pourrait résoudre de de problème la
transformation du cadre d'emploi d'Es
avec la fusion dans dans le corps des
des avec celui des AED qui à mon avis
une fausse bonne idée voire même plutôt
une vraie mauvaise idée euh et sur
lesqueles je pense qu'il y a d'autres
pistes plus intéressante et plus
importante à à mettre en place et on est
prêt à en discuter avec vous euh par
ailleurs et c'est le dernier point que
je sur lequel je voudrais aussi vous
interrogez la remise en cause du
financement par l'État euh de la prise
en charge sur les temps périscolaires et
et particul ement sur le temps méridien
de de la prise en charge des aesh pose
un un un grand nombre de problèmes parce
que l'enfant n'est plus au centre
finalement de la politique d'inclusion
parce qu'on crée des ruptures dans son
accompagnement et dans sa prise en
charge et par ailleurs l'enseignement
privé aujourd'hui se retrouve sans
solution pour la prise en charge de ses
enfants sur le temps méridien ces
enfants a besoins particulierers puisque
le mode de financement de l'enseignement
privé ne leur permet pas de financer
avec leur fofet scolaire c'est C temps
méridien et donc on a aujourd'hui un
phénomène là aussi d'ex inusion de ces
enfants du privé vers le le public c'est
souvent des enfants qui sont les plus
lourds dans la prise en charge et donc
ça nous pose un problème majeur de de
dans not politique d'inclusion j'ai j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi que
j'espère pouvoir qu'on pourra étudier
prochainement sur ce sujet et et on
souhaiterait pouvoir avoir votre soutien
afin de revenir vers une politique
d'inclusion pour tous et dans dans dans
tous les types d'établissements et pour
tous les élèves chrel oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre ça va
faire faire près de de 2 he d'audition
et il y a une grande absente dans vos
propos et depuis votre prise de fonction
qui a été soulevée par mon collègue
Zouia c'est qui est pourtant un problème
central qui est justement la mixité
sociale à l'école car s'il y a bien un
outil qui permet de lutter contre
l'assignation à résidence vous voulez
l'émancipation c'est ce que vous avez
dit dans votre propos à l'école c'est
justement de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
plus de mixité sociale à l'école alors
que on voit toutes les études que c'est
dans notre pays où la reproduction
sociale est l'une des plus fortes et
quand on regarde toutes vos prises de
position et elles ont été nombreuses
depuis votre prise de fonction je n'ai
rien vu sur ce sujet-là alors votre
prédécesseur par contre ça a été évoqué
ici même au Sénat on avait organisé à
l'initiative de notre groupe un débat
sur ce sujet et sur tous les bancs de
cet hémicycle de cette assemblée nous
étions d'accord sur ce constat là donc
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire
réellement parce que des initiatives il
y en a il y en a plein il y en a qui
sont prises aussi au niveau des
départements la hautegaron notamment et
qui ont des résultats donc il y a des
résultats concrets nous ce qu'on
souhaiterait c'est qu'on passe l'étape
d'après l'étape supérieure que vous
puissiez déployer ce qui marche en
accompagnant justement les départements
là où ça fonctionne qu'est-ce que vous
avez comme stratégie comme politique que
vous allez mettre en place pour qu'il y
ait une réelle mixité sociale dans les
établissements de ce
pays merci beaucoup monsieur le
président euh monsieur le le ministre
trois questions plus une une remarque en
préalable euh qui est celle qu'aurait
souhaité faire Patrick canner qui a
malheureusement dû s'absenter de de
notre commission euh sur l'école du
futur on en a beaucoup entendu parler à
l'extérieur de cet hémicycle et
notamment dans la dans la presse euh sur
laquelle il aurait souhaité euh vous
dire à quel point pour lui pour nous
l'école du futur c'était la façon dont
on se tournait vers l'avenir dont on on
envisageait des pédagogies innovantes
des pédagogies différentes afin de
pouvoir appréhender euh de la meilleure
manière des métiers qui changent un
monde qui change et pour lequel notre
regard sur ce que nous lisons est plutôt
celui d'un tournant libéral avec la mise
en place de classe de niveau pour la 6e
je vous entendais remarque personnelles
avec euh soulagement j'allais dire
satisfaction mais en fait soulagement
dire que vous ne souhaitiez pas revenir
sur le collège unique je crois en effet
que l'école de la sélection sociale qui
a été ce qui existait avant la mise en
œuvre du collège unique serait une
grande erreur voilà donc nous nous avons
évidemment une interrogation pour savoir
finalement queles sont les les valeurs
que vous entendez défendre à
travers le le ministère de de
l'éducation nationale quand vous parlez
d'école du futur et puis euh trois
questions très précise après ces
remarques préalables sur des sujets qui
ont pu être évoqués par mes collègues
sur lequel je j'aurai des questions
euh également le premier et vous venez
d'en parler c'est en effet le l'avenir
du fond de soutien au développement des
activités périscolaires il y a 15 jours
nous découvrons les uns et les autres
par voie de presse en concertation avec
les collectivités locales qui sont quand
même un poil concerné que le taux de
prise en charge va être modifiée
réaction des collectivités locales je
sais que la MF vous a saisi et vous avez
fait le choix et je crois qu'il était le
bon de ne pas modifier ces taux de prise
en charge mais quand on regarde le PLF
2024 ce fond disparaît
euh du coup finalement tout ça toujours
sans grande concertation avec les
collectivités locales du coup il y a
deux question quelle est la position du
ministre que vous êtes sur la mise en
œuvre de la semaine de 4 jours et demi
dans les villes qui sont encore et on
parle de métropole et de centaines de
milliers d'enfants concernés qui sont
encore avec une organisation avec 5
demi-journées d'apprentissage première
question et la deuxième question
évidemment cuid de l'avenir de ce fond
qui permet pour les collectivités qui
par exemple de rendre ses activités
gratuites lorsqu'elles ont été mises en
œuvre dans le cadre préscolaire pour les
enfants ce qui n'est pas rien y compris
au regard des ambitions que vous
affichez sur les projets et culturels
pour les enfants dans le premier degré
qui d'autres systèmes deuxième sujet mes
collègues en ont parlé c'est la question
de la mixité sociale et scolaire en
effet en 2022 nous l'avons tous
vécu ça n'est pas un sujet nouveau je
vous l'accorde et c'est un sujet sur
lequel il y a eu des tentatives de
d'avancer la publication 2022 des IPS
indice depposition
sociale si ma mémoire est bonne a mis en
lumière de façon extrêmement concrète ne
disparaissait pas vous avez perdu
extrêmement concrète euh l'inégalité
criante qui n'était plus uniquement un
sujet d'évaluation générale elle
existent elles sont nombreuses mais un
sujet absolument criant d'inégalité
sociale et scolaire des outils ont été
proposés par votre prédécesseur sur la
sectorisation multicollège multilicée
sur le fait d'ouvrir les établissements
dit favorisés avec les les les les
l'accueil des boursiers le
contramixité d'ouvrir des sections
d'excellence dans les établissements dit
moins favorisés bref il y avait un
chemin nous avons pu pour certains
d'entre nous considéraent que le chemin
proposé par votre prédécesseur était
manquait d'ambition mais avait le mérite
d'exister du coup question simple quelle
suite avez-vous prévu et dans quelle
temporalité de donner au travail qui
avait été engagé par papendia et
notamment vis-à-vis de l'enseignement
privé mais vous aurez noté que ma
question est plus large et puis dernière
question c'est un sujet sur lequel je
souhaite vraiment vous alerter c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous avons alerté vos
deux
prédécesseurs c'est l'avenir et le
devenir des jardins d'enfants
pédagogiques qui sont des structures qui
permettent à Strasbourg à Marseille à
Paris et un petit peu à Marseille
d'accueillir en milieu ordinaire et en
mixité et nous venons quand même
largement d'évoquer ce sujet aujourd'hui
des enfants en situation de handicap de
chiffre à Paris c'est 22 jardins
d'enfants 800 enfants qui sont
accueillis
et je le cite papendiaille avait je
crois dans cette instance la commission
éducation culture au Sénat reconnu que
les jardins d'enfants avaient souffert
de façon indirecte de la loi de 2019 de
la scolarisation obligatoire des moins
de 3 ans et qu'il était nécessaire de
trouver une solution juridique cette
solution une dérogation a été trouvée
par le ministre et les services du
ministère pour encore cette année ma
question est très simple pouvez-vous
prendre l'engagement les familles
attendent vraiment de le savoir les
professionnels attendent vraiment de le
savoir et les élus évidemment tout auts
pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement que ce
système de dérogation sera poursuivi ou
à tout la moins pouvez-vous prendre
l'engagement que les jardins d'enfants
ne disparaîtront pas ils participent à
des missions importantes de service
public adelsiane
oui merci monsieur le ministre de votre
présence ce soir c'est une première pour
vous c'est une première pour moi
également nouvellement élu comme
sénateur de la scène Saint- ins
satisfait cite pour commencer vous avez
cité Saint-Ouin ville dont je suis élu
avec le maire de saint-toouin Karim
bouamran et vous avez évoqué un sujet
extrêmement important la lutte contre le
rcellement scolaire et nous avons été
effectivement à Saint-Ouin depuis 2020
22 ville pilote en terme
d'expérimentation pour le dispositif
inspiré de de pays scandinaves free for
mobbery libéré du harcèlement et un
sujet qui nous tient particulièrement à
cœur je veux revenir sur deux sujets et
faire une remarque ça a été largement
évoqué la question des aesh moi j'en
parle aussi pour la scène Saint-Denis et
j'ai trois questions très précises sur
ce sujet euh nouvellement élu on sort
d'une campagne euh en scène Saint-Denis
où cette question des avsh a été
particulièrement prignante elle était
particulièrement forte l'ensemble des
élus ont fait ce constat aujourd'hui des
efforts ont été faits clairement mais
malheureusement on se retrouve encore
dans des situations dans notre
département où un grand nombre de
parents non pas même si les les maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées délivrent des notifications
pour permettre à ses parents on se
retrouve dans toutes les villes de
saint-sintenis face à des situations où
il n'y a pas d'accompagnement
individualisé vous l'avez évoqué aussi
et c'est totalement lié aussi monsieur
le ministre vous avez évoqué 15 millions
d'heures euh de cours qui ne sont pas
dispensés en scène Saint-Denis c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît bien
puisqu'on constate statistiquement qu'à
18 ans un enfant qui arrive ou un
adolescent qui passe son bac à 18 ans
c'est une année de cours en moins qu'il
n'aura pas pu suivre dans toutes les
matières donc ce n'est plus seulement
une question d'inégalité c'est une
question d'inéquité républicaine que
notre pays que notre notre Parlement
notre gouvernant doit être en capacité
de traiter je le dis parce que voilà les
questions sur ces questions de SH elles
sont elles ont été largement évoquées on
aussi c'est une piste un travail est en
train d'être mené des discussions sont
en cours entre les services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
et les municipalité pour travailler et
mettre en place des conventions pour
favoriser justement le recrutement des
As sur un statut unique éducation
nationale pour permettre une mise à
disposition des communes mes questions
sur ce sujet c'est d'abord savoir quel
est le bilan de la rentrée scolaire en
ce qui concerne le nombre de postes d'
ouvert à cette rentrée l'état des
besoins couverts et non couvert c'est un
vrai sujet sur lequel on manque
d'information et ce que les élus aussi
dans le territoire attendent les
perspectives d'ouverture de poste et de
recrutement et surtout cette question de
est-ce qu'il y a des perspective sur ces
conventions négociées dont je parlais
est-ce que c'est une échéance possible à
court terme à moyen terme pour trouver
cette mise en corrélation entre les
services des communes et les services de
l'éducation nationale dans les
départements deuxième point ça a été
évoqué très très vite les cités éducativ
euh c'est un aujourd'hui en sc saint l
nous avons enfin en France à ma con ence
il y a 200 cités éducatives labellisé
une douzaine en scène Saint-Denis vous
l'avez dit président ne parle pas de PLF
et de perspective financière mais ces
cités éducatives dont une est à
saint-toouin traduisent vraiment la
volonté des des acteurs locaux de
l'éducation de travailler ensemble elles
sont inscrite dans le cadre de
convention triénal certaines encienne
Saint-Denis ont démarré en 2020 on
arrive à leur terme il y a un
financement important de la part de
l'État et nous restons donc dans
l'attente de la confirmation de leur
renouvellement et on sait aussi que
c'est très lié euh aux décisions à venir
en matière de politique de la ville
enfin c'est ma remarque après mes deux
euh mes deux constats euh sur la
question de la mixité scolaire ça a été
largement évoqué par euh euh par
différementes personnes sous des angles
différents euh bien sûr euh moi ce que
je voudrais qu'on ait quand même à
l'esprit euh c'est que vous l'avez
évoqué vous monsieur le ministre que la
p la pédagogie peut renverser la
sociologie je cite bien vos vos propos
nous sommes bien d'accord euh pardon
tout à fait
euh mais là je pense que là on a quand
même un sujet sur ces questions de
mixité scolaire sociale et scolaire et
on est sur une forme d'impensé et de
nombreuses évaluations académiques des
recherches ont mis en évidence très
clairement l'intérêt je sais que vous
aimz lire des rapports prendre des
éléments de
connaissance pour tous les élèves qu'il
soit de milieu favorisé ou pas un
brassage établi dans la durée permet
justement de favoriser d'aider les plus
faibles sans pénaliser les plus forts et
c'est ça que je voulais évoquer en
conclusion de mon propos monsieur le
ministre c'est ce rapport aussi de
France stratégie qui a été publié il y a
pas très longtemps il y a un mois ma
connaissance qui évoquait très
précisément que l'exposition des élèves
de milieux social défavorisés ou faible
scolairement avec leur pair plus
favorisé à des effets sur les
performances à court terme relativement
mesuré mais des bénéfices de moyens et
long terme important réduction du
décrochage scolaire amélioration des
trajectoires scolaires et
professionnelles et les mesures visant à
la mixité sociale et scolaire dans
l'enseignement on donc un effet positif
potentiel important sur la mobilité
sociale des jeunes défavorisés c'est le
rapport de france stratégieque d' y a un
mois et ça je pense que dans les
discussions que nous devons avoir sur ce
sujet c'est une forme de la promesse
républicaine que l'école doit porter
concrètement que nous sommes amenés à
discuter dans les prochaines échéances
je vous remercie David
Ross merci monsieur le Président et
merci monsieur le ministre pour nous
avoir présenté les les trois piliers ou
les trois chantiers de votre feuille de
route de votre
ambition le temps passé au cours de
cette audition ainsi que le grand nombre
de questions ben montre à quel point
l'éducation nous importe et à quel point
vous comme nous collectivement elle nous
oblige alors à cet égard au-delà de vos
annonces liés à votre nomination
j'aimerais si vous le permettez remplir
votre cartable de rentrée de deux autres
dossiers qui concerne en fait des
dossiers structurels déjà existants et
de savoir si dans votre vision pour vous
ils vont rester pérennes ou s'ils sont
amenés à évoluer je veux évoquer la
réforme du bac et puis les rythmes
scolaires alors sur la réforme du bac je
serai un petit peu en écho à ce qu'a
évoqué Lord Arcos à savoirors je vais
pas revenir sur la baisse du nombre
d'étudiants en mathématique dans notre
secteur mais ce que je constate c'est
que le choix très tôt qui est demandé
aux élèves finalement quasiment en
milieu de secondes de faire des choix de
spécialité abouti en tout cas dans notre
secteur depuis 2 ans à des choix qui
sont math physique math ses et le parent
pauvre pour
l'instant c'est les sciences de la vie
or on sait qu'on a un besoin énorme de
scientifique dans le domaine médical au
sens large et la crise covid qui vient
de passer ne fait que le confirmer or
évidemment quand on voit les effets de
cela il faut généralement 5 à 10 ans
pour s'apercevoir qu'on va être en
déficite donc je voulais savoir si vous
aviez déjà des évaluations au-delà de
notre propre territoire du plateau de
saclé sur l'ensemble du territoire
français de cet impact ou pas de cet
effet ver lié à ce choix-là ce qui me
permet d'ailleurs de considérer que
lorsqu'on évoque tous les enjeux de
notre société scientifique alors là je
vais être biisé et forcément j'aurai à
nouveau une divergence ce sera la
deuxième aujourd'hui avec mon collègue
Brisson étant universitaire forcément je
ne serai pas objectif mais lorsque l'on
voit les sujets importants à venir la
santé le numérique l'intelligence
artificielle les aspects liés au clima
finalement ceux qui sont appelés à
enseigner et donc à sensibiliser les
jeunes à ces questionslà est-ce que le
meilleur endroit où ils peuvent être
formés c'est pas l'université mais
l'université dans le sens où on intègre
dans la formation les aspects liés à la
recherche ce qui me permet monsieur le
ministre de vous rappeler mais je pense
que vous le savez que votre collègue qui
habite dans la très belle ville d'orsé
est certes ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur mais aussi de la recherche et
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment que le
mot recherche apparaisse y compris dans
les cycles de formation c'est vrai
évidemment pour les enseignants du lycée
mais je pense qu'il peut aussi et c'est
l'objectif d'ailleurs dans les
formations à l'université d'avoir des
formations pour le premier degré le et
donc c'est pourquoi je dis ça parce que
ça permettra non pas d'avoir un choc des
savoirs que j'ai du mal
philosophiquement un peu à estimer mais
peut-être avoir des savoirs de choc qui
permettent deavoir des ruptures par
rapport au sujets auquels nous sommes
confrontés pour l'avenir de notre pays
le deuxième sujet donc c'est le rythme
scolaire donc excusez-moi encore de
mettre à l'honneur la ville d'orsé mais
la ville d'orsé est la dernière ville en
Nesson et je crois avec Paris peut-être
la dernière ville en Île-de-France a
appliqué le rythme des C matinées
travaillé c'est un choix que nous avons
mis nous avons mis en place avec un vote
tous les 4 ans au moment du projet
éducatif et que les parents qui sont
appelés à voter ont voté à plus de 70 %
pour le maintien de ce rythme les
enseignants dans j'imagine l'exclusive
intérêt de l'enfant eux votent en
majorité pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
mercredi matin travailler et donc le
problème que ça me pose parce que nous
l'assumons le faire et je fais partie de
ceux qui se battent pour avoir plus
d'autonomie pour les collectivités mais
là on arrive dans un un niveau un peu
schizophrénique puisque il se trouve que
la dérogation de 4 jours qui devait être
l'exception devient la règle et donc la
question que je pose à l'éducation
nationale c'est comment est-ce qu'on
fait par rapport à ça il y a des
problèmes de formation le mercredi matin
il y a des problème de remplacement
d'enseignants et donc est-ce que ce
cette réforme va continuer à être
expérimentée est-ce qu'on va avoir un
retour sur évaluation ou est-ce qu'il va
y avoir un moment une décision que on
assumera tout à fait en tant qu'élu
locaux moi je suis encore maire pour
quelques jours de la commune d'orsé mais
une décision qui dit ben maintenant on
revient au 4 jours ou on revient au 4
jours et demi mais on laisse pas cette
latitude qui fait que on a un paysage
qui est assez morcelé sur le domaine
merci Monsieur le Ministre Mathilde
Olivier merci monsieur le Président et
bienvenue monsieur le ministre alors
comme je conclus ce tour de questions je
vais donc couper dans ma première
intervention dans cette commission pour
faire un peu plus court mais je voulais
quand même rebondir sur les propos de ma
collègue du groupe S qui parlait des
petites annonces sur Facebook et vous
êtes aussi vous-même revenu sur la
qualification des enseignants
contractuels ça m'a rappelé ma propre
expérience qui est aussi une réalité du
recrutement de contractuel en 2017 je
commençais ma dernière année d'étude
franco-allemande j'étais à Lille je mets
une petite annonce sur le boncoin pour
proposer des cours de soutien en
allemand à côté de mes études et puis
donc on est fin août un collège de
Boulogne surmer m'appelle pour me
proposer un mi-temps comme professeur
d'allemand euh je précise que je faisais
pas du tout des études dans le domaine
de l'enseignement
donc j'ai bien sûr
refusé mais on imagine bien qu'on ne
peut absolument pas permettre un
enseignement de qualité en recrutant des
personnels pas qualifiés et ça montre le
niveau de difficulté dans le recrutement
dans un certain nombre de matières
aujourd'hui voilà c'était on voit euh si
enfin on voit que 6 ans après on est
quand même toujours dans la même
situation avec des petites annonces sur
Facebook et l'attractivité du métier de
professeur de plus en plus en crise
aujourd'hui euh voilà ça c'était pour
l'anecdote pour pour souligner les
propos de ma de ma collègue
euh sur le pacte je voulais pas revenir
sur le fond du problème de ce système de
travailler plus pour gagner plus mes
collègues l'ont fait maintenant sur la
mise en place de ce dispositif en
lui-même quelle est la répartition femme
homme de signature de ce dispositif
alors que c'était l'un des points quand
même critiques
euh notamment le fait que ça
augmenterait les inégalités de salaire
entre femmes et hommes et puis pour
revenir enfin sur le réseau éducatif
français à l'étranger
euh puisque faire des études supérieures
en France c'était c'est quand même l'un
des aspects importants de l'attractivité
de notre réseau français à l'étranger
donc cet été suite aux événements au
Niger et plus globalement dans le Sahel
on a eu de nombreuses sollicitations de
jeunes bloqués pour venir faire leurs
études en France suite à la politique
diplomatique française de blocage de
visa avec un impact désastreux pour nos
relations avec ces jeunes francophiles
francophones de ces pays et qui joueront
un rôle crucial dans nos relations avec
ces pays à l'avenir donc c'est un danger
pour nos établissements d'un danger pour
la EFE euh plus globalement on bloque
des élèves qui ont effectué toutes leur
scolarité dans nos établissements euh et
donc un engagement de votre ministère et
de celui bien sûr de l'enseignement
supérieur aussi euh serait essentiel sur
ces sujets donc est-ce que vous pourriez
nous faire un point sur cette situation
et puis un dernier un dernier point sur
l'augmentation d'un milliard pour les
lycées professionnels dont vous parliez
euh voilà j'espère que vous inclurez à
votre réflexion le développement des
enseignements professionnels jusqu'au
bac pro aussi dans les établissements
français à l'étranger merci dernière
intervenante
agèv Laurent alors une une intervention
vraiment très très courte tout d'abord
pour féliciter le ministre parce que je
trouve que un peu plus de pragmatisme à
l'éducation nationale et un peu moins de
dogmatisme ça fait vraiment du bien et
je voudrais donc aborder le sujet du
harcèlement qui est votre priorité et
vous parler de l'association La
maintendue présidée par Nora fres qui
fait un travail absolument incroyable et
qui hélas enregistre ce qui démontre que
vous avez fait parfaitement bien le
travail qui enregistre une hausse de 150
% de sollicitations de famille victimes
150 % et qui en même temps est confronté
à une baisse de 30 % de ses dotations
depuis 2 ans et qui donc se retrouve
dans une situation financière assez
compliqué et qui va entraver
malheureusement les interventions au
sein du milieu scolaire donc je voulais
savoir comment est-ce que l'éducation
nationale pouvait renforcer ce
partenariat financier avec cette
association et deuxièmement je crois
qu'il y avait un comité d'experts qui
avait été mis en place à l'époque par
Jean-Michel Blanquer qui n'a toujours
pas été réuni depuis qu'il est parti ça
permettait d'avoir des remontées de
terrain notamment je crois que Monsieur
papend ne l'avait pas réuni est-ce que
vous envisagez de le relancer euh parce
que je pense que c'était important
évidemment pour les famill merci Alle
j'ajoute moi une toute petite dernière
question par rapport aux différents
points que vous avez annoncé je pense
notamment à à l'École normale du 21e
siècle est-ce que vous aurez besoin
d'une loi pour mettre
en alors pour répondre à cette question
j' ça dépend ce qu'on fera plus on est
ambitieux plus le besoin de la loi
évidemment même si parfois on découvre
que il y a pas toujours besoin de loi et
compris pour des réformes très
structurantes de mémoire sur la réforme
du
lycée la réforme du lycée de mémoire
Jean-Michel blanc réforme du bac la fête
sans sans voilà donc donc il y a de très
grandes possibilités mais c'est pas
parce qu'il y a pas de loi qu'il y a pas
de débat et discussion avec les
parlementaires
évidemment en tout cas moi je serais
toujours je seraai toujours dans ce
souci et cette recherche du dialogue et
de la coconstruction uni pour notre
école c'est mon voilà mon ma boussole
dans mon action et donc je continuerai
évidemment à à travailler avec vous je
vais revenir sur les différentes
interventions je précise que j'ai
toujours fait comme ça dans les
auditions je réponds aux orateurs qui
sont restés pour écouter ma réponse
c'est pas du tout une critique pour ceux
qui sont partis puceque ça a dérivé en
terme de durée mais je pense que c'est
important de valoriser ceux qui ont fait
l'effort de rester dans cette audition
très longue et puis par ailleurs il y a
plusieurs sujets qui se rejoignent et
notamment il y a plusieurs interventions
sur la mix cé scolaire d'abord moi je
vais être très clair je ne souhaite pas
rouvrir la guerre entre les écoles et je
veux être très clair sur ce sujet je
souhaite que les parents puissent
toujours avoir le choix et en fait
c'est une considération qui peut parfois
apparître un peu théorique
malheureusement avec certaines familles
qui se disent aujourd'hui il faut le
regarder en face qu'elles ne sont plus
sûres d'avoir vraiment le choix si elles
veulent que leurs enfants réussissent
on est tous élus moi je suis élu local
aussi depuis 10 ans dans ma commune on
rencontre des familles notamment des
familles de classe moyenne qui se
demande si leurs enfants pourront
continuer à réussir et à s'élever comme
eux se sont élevés dans l'école publique
c'est c'est ça serait mentir que de dire
qu'on rencontre pas ça et je pense que
la question absolument essentielle c'est
de se demander pourquoi est-ce que il se
pose ces questions et pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils se disent parfois qu'ils n'ont
pas le choix s'ils veulent que leurs
enfants réussissent que d'aller dans le
public je crois pas du tout que c'est le
nombre d'élèves par par classe vous avez
plus d'élèves par classe dans le privé
que dans le public je crois pas que ça
soit l'état bâtimentaire des écoles
elles sont mieux entretenu notamment
grâce aux collectivités locales dans le
public que dans le privé donc je pense
que c'est sur des questions de niveau et
donc effectivement le fait que on arrive
à avoir un système où il y a toujours un
enseignant devant les élèves et quand il
y a des absences on arrive vraiment à
les remplacer de pédagogie différencié y
compris avec des organisations
différentes on a parlé tout à l'heure de
la possibilité d'avoir des groupes de
compétences encore une fois pas des
classes de niveau mais des groupes de
compétences sur certaines disciplines
dans beaucoup d'établissements scolaires
privés c'est le cas la possibilité
d'avoir plus d'expérience aussi dans la
vie professionnelle entre guillemets
j'ai annoncé un stage en fin de seconde
j'ai entendu des gens dire faut pas et
cetera enfin dans le privé dans beaucoup
d'écoles privées il y a des stages tous
les ans elle est là la vraie inégalité
aussi vous avez des élèves qui arrivent
ensuite dans le supérieur ou dans la vie
professionnelle ils ont un CV long comme
le bras parce qu'ils ont eu des stages
organisés dans un cadre scolaire dans
leur établissement et puis les autres
qui ont pas ces expériences donc pour
moi le premier levier de la mixité
sociale c'est de faire en sorte que les
familles se disent toujours qu'elles ont
le choix et que leurs enfants pourront
réussir à l'école publique et donc de
répondre aujourd'hui aux doutes et aux
inquiétudes qui existe pour beaucoup de
familles ça c'est la première chose y
compris en assumant d'investir des
moyens supplémentaires en les dirigeant
vers les établissements les plus
défavorisés l'investissement qu'on a
fait pour l'éducation prioritaire depuis
2017 il est massif avec le dédoublement
des classes avec les petits déjeunés
gratuits avec devoir fait avec la
rémunération plus importante des
enseignants qui vont enseigner dans ces
établissements encore une fois on peut
dire il faudrait faire mieux il faudrait
faire différemment faudrait faire encore
plus mais enfin c'est un investissement
massif et on voit que ça a un impact les
études montrent notamment les études de
laadep qu'on a une réduction des écarts
de 15 à 40 % sur le français et les
mathématiques entre les élèves
d'éducation prioritaire et les autres
grâce au dédoublement donc oui la
pédagogie peut renverser la sociologie
au au sens où la pédagogie peut
renverser les déterminismes peut briser
les parcours et les destins qui sont
écrits d'avance pour encore trop
d'élèves et trop de familles dans notre
pays et c'est vrai monsieur chanrel
qu'on reproduit trop les inégalités
sociales en inégalité scolairire en
France mais pour moi la réponse c'est de
montrer qu'on investi massivement qu'on
innove aussi dans ces établissements
pour donner envie aux familles d'y
rester parce que la réalité moi je vais
vous le dire je pense qu'il y a très peu
de familles qui se diront finalement que
le premier critère pour eux pour elle
c'est la mixité sociale le premier
critère pour elle c'est de se dire que
leur enfant a le plus de conditions
possibles pour réussir c'est ça c'est ça
la réalité ce qu'il faut leur rappeler
c'est que la mixité sociale est une des
conditions d'un bon apprentissage et que
les études le montrent vous avez
totalement raison en matière de climat
scolaire on voit que ça a un impact
positif mais aussi en matière
d'apprentissage donc faut toujours le
rappeler vous avez raison de le faire
mais moi je ne crois pas qu'on arrivera
à répondre à cette situation en envoyant
un message consistant à dire pour qu'il
a plus de mixité sociale on va empêcher
les familles qui le souhaitent d'aller
dans le privé on va exporter entre
guillemets les problèmes qu'on a dans le
public dans le privé pour garantir la
mixité sociale je ne crois pas une
seconde que ça fonctionnera c'est
continuer à investir en priorité dans
les établissements les plus défavorisés
cette rentrée on ouvre 15 sections
internationales on les met toutes dans
des établissements de l'éducation
prioritaire on poursuit les
dédoublements et on va continuer à
avancer avec le 8h 18h au collège en qpv
avec les 2 heures de sport en plus par
semaine bref voilà la la ligne qui est
la mienne on
pense aujourd'hui 8500 € par élève en
primaire à l'école publique c'était 7000
€ par an en 2017 quand Emmanuel Macron a
été élu on a massivement renforcé dans
le privé c'est 5000 € par an
l'investissement est évidemment
supérieur dans le public que dans le
privé il faut maintenant que ça se
ressente et que les résultats
s'améliorent on est passé de 24 élèves
par classe en moyenne à 21 élèves par
classe en moyenne en primaire depuis
2017 donc il y a cet investissement
ensuite sur l'organisation la discussion
avec l'ense enseignement privé notamment
l'enseignement catholique il y a eu
effectivement beaucoup de travail avec
mon prédécesseur ça a abouti à un accord
pour y développer la mixité sociale
c'està-dire le nombre d'élèves boursiers
on a installé maintenant dans tous les
rectorats les instances qui
travailleront territoire par territoire
pour atteindre cet objectif de mixité
donc moi je vais m'inscrire dans ce
travail là en soutien à ces instances de
dialogue et de concertation pour avancer
par ailleurs je veux poursuivre aussi ce
qui a été engagé sur les affation
notamment dans certaines académies vous
l'avez je sais plus qui l'a dit mais qui
sont allé plus loin que d'autres
l'académie de Paris par exemple a été
très courageuse et a fait beaucoup
d'effort en la matière sur les
affectations pour renforcer la mixité
sociale je dis courageuse parce que on
le sait il y a aussi des familles
derrière qui peuvent s'en plainre donc
c'était c'était voilà c'est je pense que
c'est important de de soutenir cette
politique là et c'est aussi ce dont je
m'inspirer évidemment dans les autres
académie donc je vais aussi m'appuyer
sur sur cette logique là euh sur le fond
de prise en charge euh du péri scolaire
alors vous le savez une des premières
décisions du président de la République
en 2017 ça a été de redonner aux
communes la liberté de rester à la
semaine de 4 jours et demi ou de revenir
à celle de 4 jours liberté 90 % des
communes on fait le choix de revenir à 4
jours évidemment on entend pas revenir
sur ce choix euh et on considère que
c'est la liberté des collectivités bien
ensuite la question du financement des
activités périscolaires pour les
communes qui ont fait le choix de rester
à 4 jours et demi alors que ça n'est
plus une obligation nationale depuis
2013 elle bénéficiait vous l'avez dit
d'un financement de l'État à travers le
fond de soutien qui est monté jusqu'à
400 millions d'euros avant 2017 et en
2017 on a fait le choix de maintenir ce
fond de soutien quand bien même ça
n'était plus une obligation pour les
communes ça n'était plus une compétence
obligatoire pourtant on a maintenu le
fond et qui nous a appelé du coup à
sortir de ce fond en premier lieu la
Cour des comptes qui a dit dors que ça
nit plus comp étance obligatoire ça n'a
plus de sens et vous devriez utiliser
ces moyens plutôt pour soutenir les
collectivités euh sur des dispositifs
qu'elles engagent comme école ouverte
colonies de vacances apprenantes et
cetera donc ce qui a été décidé l'an
dernier c'est de mettre fin
progressivement à ce fond et de le
diviser par deux à la rentrée 2023 puis
de l'éteindre en
2024 je précise que tous ces éléments
figuraient dans les documents
budgétaires du PLF 2020 2 donc il y a un
an je je je vais vous juste vous
réagérer c'était dans les documents
budgétaires c'était y compris mentionné
dans les rapports pour avis produits par
les commissions je peux vous ressortir
tous les éléments ce qui est certain et
ça pour le coup ça a été une découverte
pour moi en arrivant au ministère c'est
qu'il y avait pas eu de concertation
avec les élus locaux c'estàdire que
c'était dans les rapports budgétaires il
y a un an c'était écrit c'était annoncé
mais les les les les élus locaux n'ont
pas été formellement prévenus donc
effectivement
euh c'est c'est pas la bonne méthode
donc on a fait le choix avec la première
ministre de maintenir le fond pour
l'année 2023 2024 et d'ouvrir le
dialogue avec les élus pour son
évolution à comptter de la prochaine
rentrée donc on verra comment ça euh
évolue je vais publier un arrêté dans
les T prochains jours en ce sens pour
rétablir le montant des des subventions
en vigueur l'an passé et j'aurais dans
nos discussions budgétaires l'occasion
de débattre avec vous il faut voir
est-ce qu'on maintient un fond pour tout
le monde est-ce qu'on maintient pour les
collectivités peut-être les plus
fragiles les plus petites on sait qu'une
partie importante du fond aujourd'hui va
à des très grandes collectivités sur
l'exemple de Paris par exemple madame
brossell c'est autour de 5 million
d'euros c'est à peine 1 % de ce que vous
c'est moins d'un % de ce que vous gagnez
en augmentant massivement la taxe
foncière sur les Parisiens en les
matraquant fiscalement donc voilà c'est
c'est moins de 1 % de du matraquage
fiscal des Parisiens donc voilà et par
ailleurs j'ajoute j'en profite j'en
profite la mairie de Paris nous doit je
le rappelle 48 millions d'euros pour la
décharge des directeurs d'école sujet
que vous connaissez puisqu'elle a arrêté
de payer depuis 2019 mais puisqu'on
parle de l'addition je propose qu'elle
soit partagée et exhaustive
euh je viens maintenant à la question
des jardins
d'enfants sujet dont j'ai été saisi à
plusieurs reprises euh ils sont
concernés par une décision qui a été
prise et pour le coup une mesure qui a
été votée puisque c'était dans la loi
euh l'abaissement de l'âge d'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans CTA la loi de
2019 pour permettre à ces établissements
qui accueillent aujourd'hui des enfants
de 18 mois à 6 ans de s'adapter il y a
une période transitoire de 5 ans qui
avait été accordée et qui expire
effectivement à la rentrée de 2024 c'est
ça j'ai bien conscience que les jardins
d'enfants n'ont pas tout à fait été
accompagnés pour se transformer
notamment en raison de la crise
sanitaire j'ai également conscience de
l'urgence à prendre une décision parce
que vous l'avez dit les
familles concernés ne peuvent plus
rester plus longtemps dans l'incertitude
septembre 2024 c'est demain d'après les
informations dont je dispose il y aurait
de l'ordre de 70 jardin d'enfant qui
accueille non seulement des enfants de
moins de 3 ans ce qui restera possible
mais également des enfants de plus de 3
ans avec ma mes collègues du
gouvernement concerné on reviendra très
prochèement vers vous pour vous indiquer
la manière dont on souhaite avancer au
fond il y a trois options première
option on reste sur l'échéance de
septembre
2024 deuxème option on prolonge un peu
cette échéance pour se donner les moyens
d'accompagner les jardins d'enfants et
compris sur le plan juridique troème
option on permet au jardins d'enfants
existant et j'insiste bien sur le
existant uniquement les existants de
poursuivre leur activité en veillant à
ce qu'il fassent l'objet d'un contrôle
particulier pour ne pas mettre à mal
l'obligation de scolarité à 3 ans donc
je reviendrai vers vous on va avancer
sur tout est ouvert les trois
possibilités sont ouvertes sauf celles
vous l'aurez compris de maintenir un
dispositif qui permet à de nouveaux
jardins d'enfants d'ouvrir euh mais on
regardera par ailleurs je pense il faut
modifier la loi du coup si euh donc
et là aussi là voilà et les délis sont
assez réduits donc il va falloir qu'on
qu'on qu'on avance assez vite sur les
questions pardon de Monsieur zan donc
j'ai répondu sur
mixité sur l'accueil des enfants en
situation de handicap je m'étais noté
quelque chose i si vous demandiez des
chiffres précis il y a 4000 postes d'ESH
qui ont été ouverts en 2023 c'est un
nombre équivalent à 2022 à quôtité
moyenne de travail inchangé ça permet
recruter encore 6500 àes cette année
l'an prochain ce sont 3000 postes qui
sont créés ce qui nous permettra de
recruter environ 4800 àes encore l'an
prochain mais oneviendra sur les
questions de plafond d'emploi et cetera
dans la discussion sur le PLF je redis
qu'il y a un enjeu d'amélioration des
conditions de travail je redis que
l'enjeu euh de la piste de travail qui a
été ouverte à la suite de la conférence
nationale du handicap c'est absolument
pas de dire on va forcer toutes les aesh
à devenir assistant de réussite
éducative et à fusionner avec les AED
c'est s'interroger sur l'opportunité de
créer un troisème métier qui finalement
permet de faire se rejoindre aesh AED au
bénéfice des personnels eux-mêm pour
qu'il y ait un plus grand temps de
travail et donc une plus grande
rémunération et au bénéfice des élèves
avec des situations aujourd'hui un peu
Baro ù sur la pause méridienne et cetera
ça peut être très compliqué pour des
élèves en situation de handicap sur les
cités éducatives effectivement 80 cités
éducatives arrivent à échéance fin 2023
et 46 fin 2024 et nous souhaitons
relabelliser d'un bloc les 126 j'ai à ma
signature une instruction conjointe avec
le ministère de la Ville que je vais
adresser avec ma collègue Sabrina gresti
roubach au préfet et au recteur en ce
sens donc ça répond à votre question sur
le sujet monsieur Ross sur la question
de l'impact de la réforme du
lycée à ce moment de l'année on observe
en classe de première une hausse
d'attractivité des enseignements de
spécialité SVT et physique chimie en
terminal on observe effectivement une
baisse d'attractivité de la SVT donc il
y a probablement un choix
en première et vous savez qu'ils
abandonnent une spécialité entre la
première et la terminale et peut-être
qu'ils le font davantage ce choix sur la
SVT que sur d'autres disciplines en
revanche le choix des enseignements de
spécialité scientifiques sont
globalement en hausse plus 4,2 % ce qui
est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
effectivement mais je seraai vigilant
sur cette question SVT je précise qu'il
y a eu un rapport de l'inspection
générale de l'éducation nationale sur la
réforme du lycée je sais pas s'il a été
publié déjà il a été publié mais
peut-être on vous le renverra parce que
il permet de faire un point et vous dem
sur sur la réforme
euh je passe ensuite sur les rythmes
scolaires j'ai répondu sur Madame
Olivier sur le pacte et les inégalités
femmes hommes j'ai pas encore les
données genrées sur le recours au pacte
mais j'espère que dans les données qu'on
aura après les vacances de la toussin on
y verra plus clair donc je communiquerai
sur sur ce sujetl voilà je peux pas
répondre à cette question pour l'instant
mais je redis qu'il y a un certain
nombre de missions qui sont possibles
dans le cadre du PACT
y compris beaucoup de missions qui sont
déjà effectuées par des enseignants et
déjà effectuées par des enseignantes
donc voilà j'entends les inquiétudes et
les préoccupations mais je pense pas que
ça se traduise nécessairement par ce que
vous redoutez
euh sur l'accueil des en France des
élèves scolarisé dans l'enseignement
français de l'étranger dans les zones en
crise il y a eu des échanges et tr
encore très récemment entre mes services
et le ministère des Affaires étrangères
pour trouver des solution y compris
surmesure dans l'intérêt des élèves euh
objectivement on est sur des faibles
volumes des faibles nombre d'élèves donc
ça permet d'avoir ce traitement sur
mesure il faut pas hésiter dans quand il
y a des situations très problématiques à
nous les faire remonter compris
directement à mon cabinet mais on trouve
quand même des solutions avec le le
korset sur le développement de filière
pro dans le FE c'est un sujet que je
n'avais pas encore été saisi mais qu'on
peut regarder et je peux regarder ce
qu'on peut développer s'il y a une
demande locale et une volonté de la EFE
d'aller de l'avant qu'on puisse y
travailler ensemble enfin sur la
question de la association Nora fress
j'ai reçu madame fress effectivement qui
fait un travail très important avec son
son association je crois qu'elle a eu
aussi des difficultés avec la Ville de
Paris qui lui a retiré son
local non non on parlait l'association
Marion la main tendue de Madame fress
donc ce que je propose c'est que les les
élus parisiens règlent leurs questions
au Conseil de Paris Mo
mieux chacun le sait je ne suis pas élu
parisien on va laisser finir le ministre
parce que moi je réponds aux questions
hein euh donc voilà évidemment on va
beaucoup travailler avec avec elle je
sais qu'il y Ava eu quelques difficultés
avec il y a pu y avoir quelques
difficultés avec le ministère c'est
dernières années mais voilà moi mon
souhait je vais vous dire sur ce sujet
du harcèlement si on on n'associe pas
toutes les bonnes volontés voilà on peut
avoir un avis sur l'activité de telle
association sur la manière dont elle
traite il faut que tout le monde s'en
parle du sujet c'est c'est une
mobilisation collective de toute la
société donc moi je vais pas pinailler
et choisir celles et ceux évidemment il
y a toujours des contrôles qui sont
faits mais voilà on a besoin de la
mobilisation collective son association
je crois que ça fait depuis 2013 qu'elle
est engagée elle fait un très bon
travail donc voilà il faut qu'on qu'on
avance avec tout le monde j'ai eu
l'occasion de la rencontrer et donc mon
souhait c'est d'avancer avec elle et je
crois beaucoup au rôle des associations
dans les établissements scolaires y
compris d'anciens élèves harcelés ou
malheureusement de parents d'élèves
harcelés qui se sont suicidé je pense
que leur témoignage dans les
établissements scolaires c'est aussi
quelque chose de très puissant euh qui
permet j'espère de de changer les
mentalités voilà je crois que j'ai
répondu à tout le monde merci beaucoup
pour votre invitation et je me tiens à
disposition du Parlement merci monsieur
le ministre comme vous avez pu constater
nous avions quelques questions à vous
poser et vous avez en tout cas pris soin
de répondre à chacune d'entre elles avec
précision et en en nous donnant bien vos
vos orientations merci beaucoup puis à
très bientôt donc pour le
plfci